Boom.
Seems like it's been a long time.
It does.
How long has it been a Friday?
Friday?
What's today?
Monday,
Tuesday.
Monday minded to know what is today?
Tuesday,
Tuesday.
Going a long time.
For what?
I don't know.
We don't have a fucking day.
I don't know where it is.
What time it is.
Too much of a whirlwind life.
Eddie Bravo,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the flashlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight and enter in
the code name Rogan,
you will save 15% off the number one sex toy from men.
Oh boy.
Yippee
told Janet.
We're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com it's o,
n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain,
the cognitive enhancing supplement,
new mood,
which is a five HTP and l trip to fan supplement.
But you know what folks,
I'm not a scientist,
nor I'm I unreasonably smart,
so don't listen to me,
which needs to do.
If you're interested in anything,
that's nootropics and that's what Alpha brain is.
And that's what uh,
Bill,
Roman oskies neuro one is.
And there's a bunch of really good ones on the market besides the one that we
have.
But if you're interested in the one that we have,
go to [inaudible] dot com o n n I t and enter in the code name Rogan and you
will get 10% off of anything you buy there.
Anything you buy,
they're also the first 30 pills.
There is a 100% money back guarantee.
You don't have to return the product so you can just say,
Yo,
this shit sucks and you get your money back.
Hey did one is we're going to come out with a mushroom head Alpha Dog.
You know what I mean?
It's a mushroom alpha dog.
If I was at,
no,
no.
You know,
basically there's already been supplements that uh,
you know,
there's like brain factor supplements.
Like Larry's company even had a brain factors,
but what did he did is he did that and fucking ran with it and made it the best
it could possibly be.
You get the best shit,
the best quality gourmet brain factor supplement.
Right?
There's been plenty of them,
but this one's gourmet.
Um,
do the same thing with,
you know,
Dick Pills,
like those,
uh,
herbal Viagra take that shit and that shit,
you know what I mean?
Probably has some sort of an effect on you.
I think it's all about,
um,
nitric oxide.
That's a,
that's what like,
that's also in like Jack Three d and things along those lines.
Like that's one of the reasons why they say that.
Viagara it is actually like a performance enhancing supplement.
Did you know that athletes take Viagra now?
Okay.
Hell yeah.
No,
no.
Up with it actually helps your athletic performance.
Oh,
that's what they say.
That's what they tell them.
They find the Viagara bottom.
This is how you've been fucking me for two hours straight.
Oh No,
no,
no.
It's,
it's for bug muscle recovery.
It's hilarious.
Come on.
Yeah.
They fund decided to Vic study for it.
What you got to tell the bitches when you get caught with via the phone,
a bodybuilding thing,
you know,
my thing was fine.
Could you imagine if it was a grand conspiracy
and that is really what it was for you just uncovered.
They said,
hey,
let's talk about this on the podcast.
She's the music making a visual Brian,
and we haven't even started.
No,
Bro was creek
exploring?
I was a whole.
People are hearing it did see it's an illusion.
It did start,
but yet it didn't start.
It does our official sweet
tea start until the music starts,
but all that other stuff was recorded and broadcast.
So it did start you guys an a professional radio show.
You got an intro.
That's right Eddie.
You know why?
Because I want to,
if you,
if someone ever wanted to edit it,
I wanted to make it as easy as possible until you got with the advertisements
are,
but I also wanted to make the advertisements as organic as possible without
sounding like too much of a queen mushroom dog.
What does the idea of mushroom head cog,
the dog part of it.
You want to fuck like dog?
C'Mon mushroom Dong mushroom dog.
Right.
You may be a car just like a wolf,
like dog with a giant boner as the logo.
Well,
you know,
they used to say that that's where the vikings,
the vikings used to take mushrooms and I think it was the Amanita miscarry.
It was,
I think that's the mushroom they're supposedly taken and they would,
uh,
they would go into berserker mode.
They would get fucked up on mushrooms before they would go.
And Jack People,
you know,
I mean,
is there a mushroom that enhances sexual performance?
don't the mushroom experts say that being on mushrooms makes you sexual?
The Times I've been on restrooms,
I definitely was sexual.
You want a massage and sex feels awesome.
Yeah,
definitely.
I agree with that.
So in terms of like how it feels,
yeah,
like marijuana too.
I mean,
especially when you eat it.
God Damn Man,
if you and your lady like a little pop brown he together and you chill together
for an hour and wait until it kicks in and woo,
you could have some intense sex.
It's like,
it's almost like a psychedelic experience,
man.
It gets,
it gets dark.
It's a,
it's um,
I think,
I think that like,
you know,
most things that are as far as like,
feel and sensual things like music and stuff along those lines,
most of those things are accentuated by marijuana.
Absolutely.
Right.
Of course.
You're the,
you're the first person that introduced me to marijuana for people don't even
know Eddie Bravo back in the day got me high.
And then we had ice cream Sundaes.
It was the greatest experience of my life because when I started smoking weed,
everyone thought I was fucking crazy at the gym,
at Jujitsu.
I was a purple belt when I started and I just became a hemp activist trying to,
you know,
uh,
preached the truth about weed and everyone thought I was crazy.
And then I thought,
man,
if I can get Joe,
Joe was smart.
Everybody
listens to them.
If I can just get Joe Haj and his,
you know,
I knew for sure your comedy would just fucking just sprout.
I knew I was 1000000% sure.
I just had to talk you into it and you weren't easy.
It took a couple months of sitting down and talking to you.
You were like,
you know,
you were like me.
I was like,
I was not intuitive at all up until I was 28 I thought it made a fucking stupid.
I thought it turned you into a loser.
I don't think he took down long for me to do it,
dude.
There was a couple of them.
I remember one time I was on the 101 freeway going over Lankershim and out.
I had you like,
we can just start talking about weed all the time.
I would seem like a fucking,
just some insane dude if I just brought up weed.
My mission was it just,
I just had to sprinkle it in sometimes in our conversation and then I had you,
I was talking to,
I was on the freeway and I didn't want to go over the pass and lose you.
It's such an important call that I pulled over on the freeway to finish my
point.
Some stories,
some analogy,
some weed analogy,
some historical facts.
You know some shit that I was reading from Jack Herrera's book.
I had that shit memorize.
I would,
I would xerox the chapters and have make copies of the chapters and I'd be a
Jujitsu and just handing them to do this because I couldn't hand them books as I
was a brokester.
It's right.
I remember was I would pass out pamphlets of all,
I would just xerox shit from Jack Rogers.
Bill people thought I was nuts.
It was crazy.
That's totally why funny.
That's so funny man.
You're that guy.
You're that back a locker room handing out leaflets.
But Hey man,
that's what you had to do before the Internet and that's what I was doing.
I do.
I just want her to do because we're human internet.
Yeah.
Once people started to think I was crazy,
that just drove me and now I got approved of these motherfuckers that I'm so I
would bring in Pampa it's like we'll just read that just as one fucking page and
if you want read the second page and then people,
it was making sense still a lot of people,
but still,
you know,
most people like myself were totally afraid of it.
And then when I started hanging out with Joe,
it was,
it was at them.
I heard about you training.
I heard that that was an actor guide training at the gym.
It was before fear factor was like during the news radio.
And so I was like,
yeah,
there's an actor duties on NBC.
He,
you know,
he trains at night or whatever and I was trained during the day and I ran into
you once or twice go,
oh that's that actor dude.
Never watched the news radio but I saw you at the comedy store.
I love going to the comedy store.
And I was out with some chick and I'm like,
that's that dude.
The trains at my school does celebrity dude.
And then you got off stage.
I'm like,
hey dude,
I train Jujitsu.
You remember me?
And you're like,
Oh shit,
you got the Machados.
And we just started talking there.
Eddie.
Eddie thought that some of them was fucking with him at a diner cause ed
couldn't,
you didn't have your,
your contacts on this.
I didn't have my contacts on his nighttime.
I was kind of a little tipsy.
And you actually recognized me and I didn't recognize you,
right?
Yeah,
I was.
I was,
uh,
outside of your range of vision and you're like,
oh dude,
I can't see shit outside.
How bad is your vision if you don't have contacts on?
Um,
it's not that bad.
It's,
I just,
if I,
if I'm like 10 yards away from me,
you started getting a little fuzzy right now.
Do I look like a pretty girl right now who maybe have my contacts in maybe up,
maybe I no.
Steiner.
How's it most donor and I was walking.
I thought you were like hitting on the checkout or something.
Right?
But you want,
I don't,
I don't know what you saw.
I think you thought it was fucking with you.
I don't know.
I don't remember what it was.
I was,
I was just,
I don't remember what I said.
I was just like,
Yo,
Eddie,
Yo Eddie,
and for whatever reason,
like your brain misinterpreted that as someone fucking with you.
And then you're like,
oh hey dude.
Oh Damn.
I could've swore it was you saying that you couldn't see that good?
Yeah,
I couldn't see that.
Good.
And I actually thought you were,
you were fucking with me or I dunno what it was,
but I could not see that good.
That trips me the fuck out because my eyes are going,
man.
I barely knew I didn't watch news radio.
Um,
there's a lot of dudes that go to the gym.
I met you once or twice.
I was probably faded and you know,
and someone's calling me and I'm like,
I don't know what the fuck's going on.
But then you were taking privates from Sylvio at the time.
I remember you were only doing privates in the beginning.
You weren't rolling and you thought you were doing the best shit.
Right.
I was the one rolling with him
and then you guys were like on an off hour.
You invited me one time.
Remember she was giving you a private and you invited me to come down to roll
too stoned and strangled me.
It was so high.
I can totally remember that till I got you in a twister to,
oh,
did you got me in everything?
I think I just got your month.
It's like he got me a couple times,
so then it was more than once.
I think it was like twice.
I was just a purple belt.
I wasn't that good.
And you're fucking,
you came in strong.
I didn't know what you were doing.
No idea what you're doing when you went for that twist to roll,
dude,
I was so lost.
That's when we started training together.
That was so fucking long ago.
Long the ago,
and then,
and then we ran into each other and 97 in Louisiana.
A UFC.
You were with Ricky rocket.
Yeah,
I was with Ricky,
rocket drummer for poison.
I just recently met him.
We were a,
I don't think I did.
I meet him back then.
I don't know if I met him back then.
I might've met him back then,
but I recently met him at the hard rock.
He's a black belt in Brazilian Jujitsu.
The drummer of poison.
All that makeup.
Yeah.
Try to lineage.
He's hardcore martial artist.
He was way into Jeet Kune Doe as well and like weapons and shit like that.
He wasn't before Jujitsu blew up,
he was already into confluence.
Right.
He didn't and he just jumped on Jiu Jitsu,
you know,
cause he's smart and I love when people get into it.
When,
what's his name?
Jonathan Lipnick.
Nikki is on his name.
The young kid who was an it.
Was He from Jerry Maguire?
Yeah.
That young kid from Jerry Maguire's really good.
Apparently apparently Heffron roles than them.
He strangles have fraud.
That's crazy.
Isn't that awesome?
I love hearing shit like that.
Man.
That is crazy though,
right?
It's one of the coolest things that I hear when we go on the road when we do
comedy shows is how many people come out to me after the show and tell me that
they start doing Jujitsu after they listen to the pod.
I get those tweets all the time and they was tagging them until,
I'm sure he said yeah,
all the time.
All the time.
And I meet those folks when I do comedy shows.
Man This uh,
this past weekend,
Fort Lauderdale,
I met a gang of dudes or talking to me about Jujitsu gang of dudes that had,
hadn't done Jujitsu until they listened to the podcast.
It's just one after the other would come and tell him at that,
which is awesome man.
You hear shit like that.
Isn't that crazy?
Awesome.
The drummer for poison is a bad motherfucker.
Strangle people.
Yeah.
It's crazy,
right?
Fuck yeah.
Nobody wore more makeup than poison will fuck you with weapons come through with
what I know.
No one ever really gave a fuck about the dudes in the crazy hair and makeup
doing that because everybody knew they were doing that because they were rock
stars when they got insane amounts of pussy.
It's like,
it was never even,
I mean even if you were like,
oh look at what they're doing and they'll get,
you're wearing crazy lipstick and crazy makeup,
but they got so much pussy you couldn't say shit.
Yeah.
Mean,
that's basically the more feminine they go,
they're going to,
the more pussy you get,
the more you could dress like a check cause no one can say shit.
Yeah man.
I mean the hot chicks around you,
you can just start fucking it dick and you'll be fine.
No,
I got all these ticks.
I Dunno about that.
I don't know about that.
I think you would lose a lot of people with that.
I don't know.
I don't know everyone.
You know what?
You know there's rumors about David Bowie and you hear this Mick Jagger rumors
that the Rod Stewart,
but what I'm,
it's just like the Richard Gere,
a durable rumor.
You know,
you got to wonder,
you know,
how easy was it to spread a rumor back then?
I mean,
did,
did Mick Jagger and and Dave Bowie really go to bed?
Really?
That's a serious rumor.
That's an incredible rumor.
They're durable rumor.
I think it was one of the wives said it though that she walked in on them,
which is always,
it has to be in bed for that.
I think back then the internet was a the tabloids.
That's it.
Newspapers you see at the store and everyone goes to,
everyone goes to rite aid and when it goes to a drug store,
everyone goes to the airport.
Yeah,
when you see,
yeah,
those are like those crazy sites.
You can get that shit out real quick number.
It's like extra,
extra.
Read all about it.
If you made the front page of some newspaper back then everybody read the
newspaper now,
what was the last time you would write or read a newspaper?
I've rarely read news.
I go to Starbucks,
I'll read the cover and I read the cover at Starbucks.
That's it.
Go through that shit.
I'll do it.
If I'm on the road by myself and I'm really fucking board of jet,
the New York Times,
I'll get the New York times and I'll go through.
I never really get the newspaper and I probably should,
but it's like,
man,
I don't,
I don't know.
It's outdated and newspapers are outdated.
You already know all this shit in a newspaper like 12 hours before you see it in
the newspaper.
Yeah.
Rulings in an effective way of doing it.
That's why
it hurt and that's why New York Times on the iPads probably going to one day be
more popular than the regular near for sure.
For sure.
What's really important though,
real journalism is really important,
but it's real scary and it's really dangerous.
Like for someone to really dig deep,
like Matt Tie,
he be style into the inner workings of the government and corruption,
Goldman Sachs and all that shit.
Dude,
that's terrifying.
But that,
that kind of shit that's,
we need a lot of that.
There's a lot of chaos and corruption going on and it just seems every year like
it's like more and more just a part of the way we just accept that this is life.
How this life is set up the way that we don't,
we don't even,
no one's going to do anything about it.
No one's doing shit about nothing.
Just the way it runs,
man.
It's not going to go,
you know,
it's going to take a lot to shift the power back to the people.
It's going to take fucking
miracle,
man.
It's amazing,
isn't it?
I mean the situation that we're in right now,
it's amazing because this is the first time where people have really kind of
truly been aware of how the whole system runs,
you know,
and you look at all these different,
National Defense Authorization Act and this new one that doesn't allow you to do
any protests where there's secret service anywhere nearby.
Yeah,
you can't,
you can get arrested.
It's a felony,
which means you go to jail for over a year for protesting,
which is supposed to be a part of our constitutional rights,
the right to protest,
but they just recently passed the law.
Obama signed it.
That if you protest in front of secret service agents while secret service
agents or protecting someone,
it could be a candidate.
It could be a journalist,
someone who works for the widest,
whoever the fuck the secret services protecting.
If you are protesting in front of them,
that's a felony.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
That man was communist Cuba type shit.
That doesn't shock me that,
that just make fucking sense.
The way the presidency is turning out,
it's for 1000000%.
Obama is going to win again.
I mean,
they're just for sure he's going to one.
There's no way he's gotten so much done for fucking big business.
There's no way he's not going to win.
There's Mitt Romney,
it's,
he's,
he's got youtube videos where they show him lying back and forth evidence in
your face.
Him Flip flopping.
It's just blasted out.
He's caught lying so many times and he's the dude is gonna uh,
go against Obama.
It's,
it's uh,
they,
they want Obama back end.
Obama is Stan.
Let's shit set up.
No Way.
I think all the other ones
that good.
You know,
you see that though.
But you know how many old racist white people are just so looking again at white
guy back in power and especially a white republican to straighten things out.
Regular Mitt Romney,
regular people,
Mitt Romney's flip flops.
That's all well and good.
As long as people accept him and liked him enough so they can get him to be
their puppet because that's all they're looking for,
they're looking to get a puppet in place.
I don't think,
I don't think regular people going to mind nearly as much as you'd think.
You know what?
Who knows what the fuck has happened.
And that's just my guess.
My guess is my guess is it has 1000000%.
Obama's gonna win.
It looks,
it looks like he's being set up to win.
He's just,
he's just looks like so powerful right now.
Roseanne Barr is Christ.
That guy's a joke.
Roseanne Barr.
Why?
Why do you say,
well,
he's up for,
she's trying to be president.
It should really?
Yeah.
She was in this place at eight the other day,
the waitress had his badge on it.
Susan or Roseanne Barr for president.
And I was like,
why?
Why do you have that?
She goes,
oh,
she's running for president.
And she was here like an hour ago.
Well,
I'll tell you what,
dude.
She for sure to be governor,
you know,
she wanted to start off as governor and work your way up to president.
If there's any woman who I think might be able to do something like that,
she could do it.
Well,
it sends a powerful woman.
You know what I mean?
That's a bad ass bitch.
I mean,
Roseanne Barr was a killer standup comedian.
She was a killer man back in the day.
You know,
it's crazy.
Look at that picture of,
tell you what dude,
she's fucking smart man.
Read or tweets.
She said some smart shit.
She's cool.
She's,
you know,
she's,
she's obviously crazy.
She's a comedian.
We're all crazy,
crazy in bed.
Oh,
Brian,
you think?
Yeah.
Why don't you ask Tom Arnold burn
when you're a dude like Tom Arnold.
That's a,
that's a tricky situation.
There's so obviously he's a talented guy.
We,
Tom Arnold,
I like Tom Arnold.
I've been on that best damn sports show with them.
It's very nice guy and obviously talented.
He's really funny in that movie.
Did what?
All towards and anger.
But when you're a dude and you're married to one of those super powerful women,
like,
man,
that's gotta be a weird spot.
He seems like he would give me heart palpitations just being around him,
you know,
it just seems too intense and fast.
Like,
I dunno,
I dunno.
He was cool.
I liked him.
But that's a tough spot being,
being married to the super woman,
you know,
that's hard.
Good luck with that.
Usually the,
they'd be like a really quiet personal trainer type dude.
So do to gets like really good massages or can eat or box.
Did you hear about all those hookers?
What ha the hookers in New York City or to Colombian secret service.
Yeah.
Yeah,
they were awesome.
The secret service were in a brothel and Columbia and apparently one of the
secret service guys refused to pay and uh,
it became like this big thing where they brought in the police,
you know,
cause you can't just do that.
And so,
uh,
this is their story.
Who knows what really happened.
But apparently the secret service was just going at it in Columbia.
Yeah.
They went there like a week early and just getting wasted and getting girls.
And I guess there's up to like 15 girls that,
that checked in because it's his story ever get out.
This seems to me like who the,
how could anybody mismanaged something like this to the point where they are led
this story get out?
Well because there's so many people involved in every time a,
a hook,
the hookers or I think it legal there.
So they work these things with the hotels for security reasons.
Like if you're going to be coming in the hotel to be a hooker,
then you have to leave your id at the front desk.
And uh,
so it's kind of like on paperwork,
like it's illegal,
it's tolerated,
but there's also a trails for everything.
Oh,
I see what you're saying.
So while we don't know what happened,
but apparently she said that he didn't want to pay.
That's what you said.
Uh,
I dunno.
I think that's what it is.
Like something happened up there.
That part.
I know it's so soon.
What does it so shocking?
The secret service guys would like some socks.
Yeah.
They're big brawny men that are,
uh,
assigned to protect one of the most powerful people on the planet.
Can they get a little sex?
Does that okay.
But you went to crazy is that these guys,
Hayden,
he's hookers were allowed inside their hotel rooms where they had like
itineraries for what?
Like Obama schedule was.
While he's going to be visiting and stuff like that.
Like,
like insane shit,
like sloppy shit.
That's really fucked up.
Oh,
you sure about that?
Yeah.
Heard it on Howard today.
Oh,
okay.
I don't know.
I think I reserve judgment until I know anything.
I don't know what really happened.
Who knows?
You know,
when,
when someone says as long as there was single,
you know what I mean?
Who Cares?
The all the,
uh,
you know,
it was,
um,
well someone said that he didn't pay.
That was like the big dispute or something.
Has something happened where someone,
which is crazy because I didn't know exactly what went down word for word like
this.
Wait a minute,
I didn't fuck you in your ass while you talking me 300.
[inaudible]
call your manager.
Call them,
call them.
Call your manager.
You know what the fuck I am?
I'm secret service bitch.
Whoa.
You think that's how the role did you imagine?
That'd be crazy.
So to speak,
in a secret service.
I would watch the,
you know,
there's these,
um,
folks,
uh,
at this production company that used to do that.
Jesse Ventura show the conspiracy theory show and I was talking to them about
this idea that they have and the wait if we get producers of that show.
Yes.
The producers of that show,
I was talking about to them about this idea that they had and as we got talking
somehow or another,
we got to talking about conspiracy theories because of that show and uh,
what they wanted that show to be,
what it ultimately became and how,
like did they weren't happy with the direction that it all went,
but they started talking to me about JFK and they're like,
like if you like,
have you seen our special on JFK?
I was wearing,
you know,
I mean,
I'm,
I'm pretty familiar with the case.
You know,
I,
I know it pretty well.
I've,
I've read several books about it and I've watched a bunch of different
documentaries on it.
Well,
they gave me this,
that the Jesse Ventura episode of it.
It's fucking,
it's pretty interesting,
man.
It's hot.
Yeah.
It's pretty entity with learning the new things.
Well,
you know,
it's,
they set up a rifle thing.
We could see like the distance of how far he was shooting from the window and
like how accurate,
you know,
you could be with that rifle in that amount of time in six seconds,
fire off three shots
and you watch that and you go wow,
that's not likely.
It's not likely he did that.
So what's your theory on who did it and how did they get away through the,
well this is the other thing.
They,
they focused on this guy,
he Howard hunt who uh,
is an unknown assassin and known CIA agent,
a guy who was,
you know,
he was,
uh,
arrested in Watford Watergate and wound up doing time for that.
So you believe he was at Sas death by deathbed?
The CIA?
Yeah,
for sure.
I think if I had a gas,
yeah.
Cause he wanted to abolish the CIA.
Yeah.
I don't,
I think Lee Harvey Oswald probably wasn't innocent.
I mean it was,
it was pretty obvious that Lee Harvey Oswald was some sort of a government
agent.
But it seems more than likely when you look at all the evidence about how
fucking ridiculous the whole scenario was,
the way they were parading him in that open area with w where was totally
unprotected.
The president with the roof down and he slowed down around the turn.
The secret service guys are so much shit.
There's so much shit they,
this is a setup.
They set this up when they killed that fucking guy.
Yeah.
For someone.
For people not to at least say there's something fishy going.
Like what?
What is fishy to you?
Like you look at nine one one shit.
There's just so much fun.
Isn't it fishy that tower seven just fucking got demo.
Isn't that fucking fishy?
It does not ring a fucking bell.
Just so much nonsense with the,
with with the case,
the,
the single bullet theory is often debated.
Okay.
And the,
the scary thing about it is how many people are willing to come up with some
this weird,
irrational explanation for why this one bullet did all these unlikely things and
then wound up on the Gurney.
And the only reason for that is because that one bullet helps negate the
possibility of conspiracy and attribute all three bolts to one guy.
And it's the only real reason to do it.
And the only reason they had to attribute this one bullet to all these wounds
was because there was a man under the underpass.
And this guy got hit in the face by a ricochet.
The Rick of the bullet hit the curb right in front of them.
And the,
uh,
the Kerbstone came up and fucked his head up.
So this guy had to go to the hospital and he told them what happened.
So they had,
they knew that was a shot that was in the record and they knew there was one
other wound to Kennedy that was in the record.
So the headshot or before the headshot,
the one that hit him in the back had to do all of his damage.
And then all the damage to governor Connally's.
Well since the only reason why they attributed to this one bullet and then they
magically find this bullet on a Gurney in the hospital and then the bullet
doesn't even have any damage to it.
The bull,
it looks like a bullet been fire through water.
It doesn't look like a bullet looks when it goes to two human beings.
It just doesn't period.
I mean,
it's nonsense.
Every single test that they've ever done with,
they've tried to duplicate it.
They haven't been able to.
Mythbusters wasn't able to.
Every time they hit bone it,
fuck that bullet up.
It shattered that bullet.
That bull was all contorted and twisted,
not the magic bullet.
The magic bullet came out in near pristine condition,
like they shot it into a million pillows.
It looked amazing.
It didn't even look flattened.
That's some scary shit.
It's scary as fuck that people were willing to accept that.
The only reason that that is on record is because they wanted a conclusion that
they had already come up to would they?
They'd come up with is Lee Harvey Oswald was guilty long before this was ever,
this was ever a question.
It'd be hot to crave so much shit.
So much evidence of they wanted Lee Harvey Oswald to be guilty.
That was period.
That's what the Warren Commission was set up to show that Lee Harvey Oswald was
guilty.
That's why that best evidence book is so creepy.
It's fucking creepy subject,
isn't it?
That they killed the president.
It will be really cool to have.
It wasn't like Marilyn Monroe and Jimmy Hendrickson,
like a hot air balloon with two sniper rifles or something.
Like if it was something that sexy and awesome,
if they did a legitimate legit investigation where they were after the person
who shot.
If there were,
it would have a,
there was just too much fishy shit.
They wouldn't have.
They wouldn't.
They would have went after it.
Yeah.
Well the photos of the Howard hunt or ridiculous cause there's a photo of him.
They arrested three Hobos that when they were arrested,
by the way,
right outside the area where the grassy knoll is,
where the supposedly the head shot came from.
The reason why Kennedy's head goes back into the left and there's a photo of him
when they were arresting these three Hobos.
He's Hobos were not Hobos,
man.
They were.
They looked like,
yeah,
they look like young men,
healthy people that didn't look like there's anything wrong with them.
They didn't look fucked up.
They look and he,
Howard Hunt is clearly in that photo.
You can pull the photo up.
He Howard hunt a JFK assassination photo and there's an,
yeah,
that's it man.
So you could see him see that guy with the hat and the back that is he Howard
Hunt
and the they've done.
They've taken photo images and put his face over the face of of e Howard hunt,
his bone structure and everything and matches.
Exactly.
That guy was a killer.
That guy was a fucking killer and he was hanging out behind the grassy knoll,
the arrested those guys and then let them free it.
Didn't charge him with shit like hipsters now didn't charge him with shit
despite all the evidence that there was someone in the grassy knoll shooting
shooting guns,
there was all these people saying that shots were coming from behind them,
that we're standing in front of the grassy knoll.
They had all these witnesses and a huge amount of people mysteriously died that
were witnesses to this shit.
A huge amount.
There was a documentary they did where they,
they,
we talked about the odds.
What,
what the odds were that all these people who had witnessed the Kennedy
assassination would be killed in either violent murders or a horrible car.
Accidents or fires or you know,
train track accidents where they parked their car and train tracks.
They killed a lot of fucking people.
Man.
You know,
it's,
it's really possible that they tied up all the loose ends.
It's really possible that they killed the president and then they went out and
they killed a whole bunch of people that might have been able to tell that they
killed the president
and they clean that shit up.
Nice.
And they put it in a big book.
And they call it the Warren Commission report.
And then there you go.
There you go.
One like the nine one one commission reports.
Same thing.
Do you think that anything they think,
do you really think nine 11 was a conspiracy?
Is that what you're saying?
For sure.
I think it's just so damn fishy manages so much.
I mean,
as an efficient fishy,
that tower seven got demos tower seven it's fishing is phots fishy,
but what's possible to me,
it's always possible in the back of my head that you got to look at
incompetence.
1500 engineers and architects and architects,
they say it's all bullshit.
That is tower seven right?
That's what their dispute is.
It's not one and two though,
right?
Uh,
well see the thing about one and two that a lot of people don't know when we're
talking about the towers,
it fell.
It's crazy.
Nine one one gets PVC.
Shit.
Fuck you real good.
I'm shutting this off right now.
I'm tired of you fucking pseudoscience towers one.
In Tower two we're really the only tower that we know of that's ever been hit by
a full jumbo jet.
Full fuel like that,
and who knows.
It might've been that design just was not really the right way to go if you're
going to get hit by a fucking plane because if you watch the way one in to fall,
to me,
they fall like a building that's falling apart,
which is like I would,
what I would assume would happen if if it started,
you know,
crumbling and crushing,
like it would fall apart that way.
When you look at tower seven now tower seven it goes into its base,
it collapses into its base.
It doesn't collapse from the top down and pancake like one and two.
There's video of it.
There's several angles of it.
We need to get to the bottom line.
It was left out of the nine one one commission report and then the explanations
for a fucking retarded.
You know,
nest came out and they get a presentation.
It's on Youtube and I s.
T.
It's ridiculous.
You think though,
here's what an alternate explanation do you think that tower seven first of all
was the the how it's the less sinister possibility.
Tower seven was home to a lot of different organizations,
right?
Like it wasn't the answer and there was a lot of different physical records that
were kept there that were lost completely in the demolition.
Is it possible that if you have a place or a building that's filled with so much
sensitive information,
so much dangerous sensitive information that they might have built it with the
designed to implode it whenever they want it to and in the case of a breach and
case of the possibility of losing all that information to you don't other
governments or or what have you?
Well,
if that was the only thing that was fishing,
there's like a thousand things,
right?
They're just so much shit.
That's just the most obvious.
That's the only thing I've looked at for that was the most not look at like the
Pentagon and all that shit.
There's so much,
but it is also possible.
I do also reserve the possibility that,
I don't know shit about architecture or engineering.
And then if you start a massive fucking gasoline fire in the basement of a
building and it turns into like essentially like one of the inside of one of
those green egg ovens,
I don't think before the fall apart.
Look at tower seven.
There's several angles.
It gets demoed right in the middle of all that shit.
Well it certainly looks like add that to everything else.
And then you saw what,
what people are capable with JFK,
you know it's business as usual.
Did No,
maybe,
no,
I'm,
I'm not saying it's not,
but I'm saying one of the things that's interesting is even though it does go in
like a controlled demolition,
it doesn't blow out like a controlled demolition.
It's almost like maybe they just like did a really sweet one.
We got a really nice way of doing this.
Minimal explosion really just kind of falls apart.
This information doesn't seem important enough for that though.
Like,
like,
like yeah,
it's security.
Security got breached,
but it also was an airplane.
Did it aside of a fucking,
you know,
building.
I don't think that that was like people jumping up there playing,
going like get the documents,
get all the important information,
you know?
They know.
I'm not saying that.
I'm saying that they built it to be able to do that to it.
You know what I'm saying?
You know what?
The very moment they built it,
they knew that they were going to have the NSA there.
They knew they were going to have the DEA documents,
whatever the fuck they've got going on in there,
whatever crazy shit bankers there was.
There was a lot of different,
like really high level government organizations that have been run out of this
building.
If they wanted to design it like so that if at anything happened,
if there was a fire one day they can just crush it.
They can just bring it down to the ground.
Maybe.
Maybe they got,
seems like a small possibility.
It's a small one that seems like that's if they went into stands out a little
bit because it's not that I don't think.
Okay.
Because my question,
if it's not that,
but what is it they want?
What they loaded up the building while everybody was working in it.
That's highly unlikely.
It's,
it's highly unlikely that you could get away with loading up a building.
It takes weeks.
There's a laptop
up.
Yes.
Well when's the last time you remember talking about this?
Lots of evidence of there's lots of evidence.
Eyewitnesses.
Crazy.
Like for weeks and weeks,
workers coming in,
certain fans,
like there's a lot of testimony.
They're like,
yeah,
we just see these guys that work in here at off hours.
And Really?
Yeah,
there's so much evidence.
It's,
they did such a sloppy job.
They just want an,
so who are these guys?
These guys that went and um,
who knows who all these explosives they're doing now is,
we don't know someone did it.
Someone did it.
Tower seven control demo staff of Starbucks.
And then look at,
look at the Pentagon.
They're saying a plane crashed into it.
And when you look at the rack there,
there's no plane wreckage.
That's another huge one.
The Pentagon,
a missile hit it or,
oh,
that was a bomb.
It was one on one or the other.
They finally released the explosion.
The three frames.
There's no plane.
Well,
there's something.
It hits it.
It looks like a missile,
but there's no record judge.
But is it,
it's no records isn't there.
Why haven't I?
Haven't I seen photos or you've got to look into this
now you see,
what'd you see as a photo up close of like some machine thing like up close.
That's not what I want to see.
What do you ever want to see a picture of backpack?
The whole front lawn where everything's all fucked up and there's suitcases and
there's tennis shoes and there's shit that you see and there's been plenty of
planes wrecking.
They know what playing records looks like.
You see fucking seats everywhere.
They just came back and sprinkled some shit down immediately.
I remember when it was going on.
No one.
When you think about what got blown up in the Pentagon the day before,
nine one one Donald Rumsfeld,
you can go,
goes on.
Yeah.
He goes,
he goes in front of the Jesse Ventura.
She,
yeah,
it's a,
you can also see on Youtube,
Donald Rumsfeld,
the day before nine one one,
he has a press conference explaining how we just found out that the,
uh,
the enemy is within the,
somewhere in the Pentagon we have the enemy and we're going to find out,
it turns out were two point $3 trillion,
a two point $3 trillion a missing from the Pentagon.
So we need a,
that's what they just figured out in accounting.
That's what he's just talking about the day before.
Next Day fucking nine one one goes down,
a missile blows up the accounting office and all the accountants will,
there's photos,
Brian.
Sure.
It's CIS.
If this was a CR,
that cy episode,
you would definitely look at that.
Right?
You know,
that's some fishy shit.
That is Brian,
do me a favor and pull up that,
uh,
Jesse Ventura conspiracy theory thing.
It's on youtube.
Go to youtube and write a Jesse Ventura conspiracy Pentagon did.
They blew up the accounting office and the account and stayed.
The ones that just figuring out that we were,
that they,
whatever they did,
they swindled two point $3 trillion.
Yeah.
Jessie,
this Torah conspiracy theory,
Donald Rumsfeld,
I want to know how they steal it.
Pentagon?
Yeah.
When,
let me see if this is the one.
Okay.
This was a c so when you put all that melted together and I can put all that
shit together.
Fuck you guys up to,
that's up to no good here.
I've been governor a navy seal
or we don't have to hear this part.
I just like hearing how I think it's time you get the story.
Is this the
clip we're looking for?
Is this the whole episode though?
Not,
I don't know.
Oh yeah,
that's fine.
Is the whole episode.
Dude,
we can't do this and what are you looking for?
I just want the one Donald Rumsfeld quote.
Oh yeah,
just go put Donald Rumsfeld.
Nine 10 oh one
put that shit on.
Let's listen to that.
What do you got to say about that next day?
The only part of the Pentagon that's blown up as the accounting office brunch.
Just try to find that shit.
I don't know.
It's,
I know.
It's um,
it's Donald Donald Rumsfeld.
DDS might be at six minutes long now.
No,
that's,
I know you'd have to secretariat.
Yes.
A press conference where he reports that they have simply lost tooth point $3
trillion.
They don't have receipts for it.
They don't know where it went.
Do you recall that the day before nine 11?
Well,
if you don't,
that's what happened.
According to some estimates,
we cannot track two point $3 trillion in transactions.
I got the exact place that was struck in the Pentagon,
which were all those records were supposedly had to be now all destroy show,
I guess the two point 3 trillion.
We as taxpayers just say,
say,
let me,
isn't that a bit much?
Did he just punch it?
All the [inaudible] been confiscated putting national security and we're not
allowed to view the plane hitting the Pentagon and don't come back with me.
But they did.
You saw that little flash,
a five frame,
three Warren Commission.
The government has a tremendous propensity for secrecy and the Defense
Department and others do as well.
You believe that the lawyer admits our government still hiding the truth from
you and me.
There was no rubble outside,
but there was all,
there was was a whole what happened to where the wind shear that question to our
nine 11 commission staffer who was the only survivor from that room who made it
out.
I did talk to April Gallop who was actually inside the room in the Pentagon and
she looked me in the eye and told me unequivocally I saw nothing that indicated
a plane hit the Pentagon.
I felt that bomb had exploded
cause always have different versions of different things.
Well that's a ridiculous statement.
Hold on.
A lot of questions that indicate that of course you would feel like a bomb hit
it right.
If any kind of I,
I mean it really is a bomb.
What does a bomb?
It's an explosion and that's what fucking happens when a plane flies into a
fucking building that isn't explored was like watching Steven Seagal rabies.
You saw it.
You saw the footage of the mind frame that they released.
There's no plane.
That chick,
you put it all together.
It's so hard to see what it,
that is so hard to see what that is,
which is why they released it.
But there's photos off man.
Come on.
Weird.
They're playing.
That's ridiculous.
Weird that a plane,
you know they've,
they've had people like trying to emulate that,
that physical force of like pulling a plane into those g's and they haven't been
able to do it.
Just if you put it all together,
Donald Rumsfeld talking about the day before we're talking about the,
they just figured out their two point $3 million is missing and then they blow
it up.
Come on Brian.
Do that favor.
Do me a favor and pull this up.
Pull up.
What was the exact freeze and it was uh oh,
a flight simulator flight simulator.
Nine one one Pentagon fail.
Yeah.
The guy that keeps trying it over and over again in a flight simulator and he
can't get it to work hard.
It's just too hard.
He can't get it.
He can't do it.
They have expert pilots trying to do it.
They can't do it.
It's something was flying like inches off the ground.
What is it?
Well,
you know,
the other thing is would if,
uh,
you know,
whatever it hit,
what if it was under remote control?
Would,
if there was a way to do it manually,
like with,
uh,
a remote control that a,
a person physically couldn't do flying a plane for person physically couldn't
control it.
Yeah,
that's what they're saying.
That's the reasoning.
Why much shit,
dude.
They're just,
and then there's other layers to that,
that norad,
they just ignored all that shit for.
Like they had a stand down pushing so much shit there.
You could do three hours on it.
It's all a big fuck up.
They fucked up and you knew they,
they knew they could fuck up and they knew no one was going to stop it.
It could,
it could be mass and competence to mixed in with some fuckery.
It could be a little bit of both.
You know what I'm saying?
Like it could be some fuckery mixed with just real government in compounds can
act called the bullshit liberties.
It was all bullshit.
Weapons of mass destruction,
all that.
They're on TV in front of the world,
lying their ass off and they know they can get away with it.
And George W.
Bush and Obama,
they're all in the same fucking bad man.
They're all just lie on their asses up.
Obama is the biggest fucking liar out there.
That guy,
just foolish shit had when he was running for the,
for the presidency,
he had posters of Shaked Guevara in his office and Oh man,
he fooled me right there.
I'm like,
damn,
the guy's a shake of RF at night.
That's a fucking revolution.
Meanwhile,
he's been one of the worst people we've ever had as far as like taking away
civil liberties.
I mean,
credit's not a melodramatic statement,
Ladies and gentlemen.
If you look up the National Defense Authorization Act and look up this new one
that makes it illegal,
it's a felony to protest near a secret service agent.
Holy Shit.
Obama was for full protest.
He fucking signed it,
man.
Peaceful protest about all that.
We talk in the beginning,
Oh,
if I'm president,
I'm going to push for legalization,
pop,
the whole weed,
the whole weed community,
the whole culture,
the whole business.
They were all behind Obama.
They thought Obama was going to be the one to push it through,
make it legal across the board,
legal,
adult use.
You know,
they got behind Obama.
There were fighting for him,
the whole wheat,
and then he turned his back,
you know,
but it was all planned anyways.
It wasn't like he just like,
he all of a sudden he became just an evil.
Fuck he's that's been planned.
This is all planned.
This is all bullshit.
They're slowly taken away our freedoms,
day by day increments in increments,
and we're all just sitting there watching it fucking go and no one's even paying
attention.
Really amazing.
This is all you need to know.
Ladies and gentlemen,
really just put this into your head.
Anybody that's trying to take away your right to peacefully protest is not your
friend.
They're not looking out for you.
They don't want you to be able to talk about the shit job they're doing.
They want it to all just sink in like the evening news,
the big fucking stupid smile on their face.
That's not good.
There's no way to rationalize it.
It's not American.
It's against the constitution.
But does it surprise you?
No.
Does it all?
Look man,
I've been watching this game of Thrones.
You ever watch that show?
No.
Oh Dude,
I'm hardcore dictum among the like five episodes in,
but one thought about hardcore addicted.
It's all like,
it's based on this fantasy land,
this a middle,
a middle earth.
You know like there were like winter is like fucking 10 years long and summer's
like nine years long and there's dragons and,
but the,
the,
my,
my point was these motherfuckers are just constantly trying to jack each other
to get better positions to constantly worrying about being jacked by some other
people coming over the hill.
They're constantly worried about getting fucked up by the dude's from the north
who want back their land.
It's just,
and you realize that's,
this is just like,
there's no difference between now and then.
I mean we're not used to seeing dudes sword fight in the street like they were
back then,
but there's not that much difference between now and then.
It's all just done through different machinery in different language and
different methodologies and then you know,
different governments working together to do it and doing as nonviolently as
possible.
But when the shit hits the fan,
the boys hit the shore guns and hand fucking tanks rolling over the ground
because somehow or another there's some shit going down in Afghanistan that were
really,
it's really important that we're there to stop it.
We've got to stop Afghanistan.
W what?
What,
what?
I mean it's so transparent,
so clean.
Like there's really,
there's really no room for it to be anything other than what it is.
It's like,
oop.
There you go.
Do you think it's ridiculous war what were were going to attack North Korea
soon?
No.
You don't think so?
I think North Korea needs,
they need food man there,
those people can't even get their rockets launched.
They launched a couple of failed a couple of different rocket launches I think
we're going to work against and very soon in fact been hearing a lot of people
being called to shore are calling.
Did Daddy really?
Yeah.
A lot of people like it's weird.
Really?
Where have you been hearing this?
Maybe I just made it up.
Am I allowed to talk about that?
Probably not,
right?
I don't know.
I don't know man.
That's some dark shit when he know somebody who's about to get called up like
people.
There's somebody I know that's like 45 and like he's been out for awhile and
they called him back at St starship troopers.
Man.
It's not like the bugs are coming.
We've got to fight them off.
Okay.
This is other people.
There's other people on the other side of the world rocking it however the fuck
they do and for whatever reason we've got to go in and interject and fuck with
their way of life and fuck with their existence.
It's crazy.
It's really crazy.
That's not what are patriotic Americans that are serving because they really
want to help this country.
That's not what they deserve.
What they deserve is to be involved in just wars.
Only what they deserve is to be at home and and it to be,
you know,
with their fucking families and not have to use our resources to keep them over
in some spa where they don't fucking need to be.
It's nonsense.
You're not going to fix Afghanistan.
You're out of your fucking mind fit.
That place is crazy.
It's all,
it's,
there's one city,
Kabul and warlords everywhere.
It's like they're like mountains and shit.
You,
you ever see the videos of like the,
the troops spring back like shit,
like home movies,
the mountains of Afghanistan like God damn,
that is crazy.
They're like in some nutty Lord of the rings movie over there.
Nobody's fixing Afghanistan.
Get out of there.
It's just another Vietnam.
It's another thing that we're going to regret.
It's that the sooner they get out of there,
the better.
But they never will.
They never will because they're in it for the money and that's why it's so
transparent.
That's what that scene do.
You really think that anybody high up with the real greenlight power thinks that
they're trying to help Afghanistan?
I think there's,
you know,
money is the bottom line like heroin,
the oil,
all that kind of shit that's all involved.
They do help and that,
that helped.
They use to justify what they're doing over there.
I mean they can do that.
I think eventually a rack will be in a better position.
I don't know.
Well,
you know what?
I don't even say that now because we left.
Right?
The United States is officially like leaving Iraq.
It's only going to be like a few thousand soldiers or something there.
Isn't that the case?
That's right.
And I think the only reason those people are there is because we bought all that
property from,
you know,
we bought property then.
Isn't that hilarious?
And we could even say that.
That can't be true.
Right?
We buy it.
Yeah.
We always bite.
We always go into countries and buy properties and buy properties and put up a
bass.
Boom.
What a nutty country we are.
It's fascinating times,
man.
It's fascinating times.
There's going to have to be some sort of a fucking mass awakening though.
There's no way we can keep up this ridiculous psychotic pace with all the access
to information that we have.
The only way we're to get there.
As we got to get into question mode,
started questioning everything.
Don't accept.
Look into it.
Even if it turns out to be totally benign,
look into it.
There's some stuck in fishy shit going on.
Yeah,
but resources to look into it.
Questions,
Shit.
Don't just accept,
should,
don't think.
Don't think that your government is out for your best interest.
It's not that way that way at all.
Politicians are just at the high levels.
They're just getting theirs and they don't care who's in their way.
The real problem,
those resources.
The real problem is there's a lot of people out there that don't have any
fucking opportunity for employment.
This is fucking not much,
man.
And the United States army,
marines,
air force,
what have you,
is the best career option for them and then that's legit.
That's legitimate.
A lot of parts of this country,
man and some parts of this country,
we're dudes.
We're trying to find a way out,
you know,
and when the marines come along and offer you guidance and discipline in a way
to pay for college,
you know,
for a lot of dudes that that's helped them.
That's helped.
I know a lot of people that it's changed him for the better till they use u two
wars break out.
Cause I remember dudes when dudes joined the marines when there was no war.
That's a,
that was a different sort of experience.
That was a guy with joined the marines to toughen up.
But once,
once war started happening,
man,
that's a completely different gig because now you're actually going to go and
you're going to be involved in some insane one on one combat where you shooting
guns at each other.
You know,
I mean that's more than likely going to happen.
Imagine that.
So few resources that that's a viable career option for a lot of people.
But it is,
you know,
we were lucky.
It's not us,
but it is for some folks and then that fucking sucks.
And I think a lot of that is because so much shit gets made in other countries
now.
There's not the nearly the manufacturing base that America wants had,
especially with like cars and shit.
You know,
we used to have like the dopest cars in the world,
you know,
America had like,
back in the day when you know GM and Ford would like do battle to have like the
coolest cars where like mustangs and Camaro's we made some cool ass shit.
But slowly but surely that just fucking fell apart.
Slowly but surely that just crumbled and tumbled.
Did you ever see Roger and me now,
Michael Moore movie about Flint,
Michigan?
No.
GM closes a plant in Flint,
Michigan.
Dude is dark.
It's a dark fucking movie.
It's brilliant.
And it's all about Michael Moore trying to find out,
like he tries to get an interview with this guy who was the head of GM and find
out why he did that and see what he did to this town when he pulled out.
I don't know if he didn't,
if he lied to them or some,
something happened and these people just were totally,
completely unprepared for this.
And he said just simply abandoned it.
And the whole town is like,
it's,
it's just crazy to watch how poor people were mad.
People were selling bunnies for food or pets and like,
you know,
so you would say food and the lady like grabs the bunny.
Like she's got this Bonnie in her,
in our lab,
but just patent it and you say food and she grabs a bunny by the fucking back of
the head,
breaks its neck and then just cuts it open.
Right,
right on camera.
And she's doing this,
you know,
it's like,
wow,
this is in the movie.
I couldn't walk.
I know you couldn't.
That's why I'm telling you about it right now.
How is the,
cause I know you're in love with bunnies.
I mean it's,
you know,
how lovable bunnies are.
So this lady is touching this bunny.
And then when you know,
when they say food or pets,
she did see,
you know,
since food.
So she kills it.
When,
when you think about that,
that life gets that hard where you have this cute little bunny and you're like,
all right,
snapping it's snack time to eat it and now that's like you're getting down.
That's an animalistic sort of a vibe you're getting into.
You're getting into this weird,
you know,
that's a,
that's a weird world you're living in,
man.
You're,
you're eating your pets.
I mean,
that thing is,
you know,
that's dark.
There's one thing to separate.
We separate like the chickens are outside and I'm going to eat those chickens.
My Dog,
I'm not going to eat my dog.
You know,
there's one thing,
but when you,
when you're eating your dog too,
that's,
you've gone into the dark zone,
you know,
you've,
you've gone into this weird desperation mode.
You're eating pets.
Don't read of mice and men either MD.
Yeah.
There's a lot of that to George is not good with the robins.
Right.
I want to do as Hobos off the dogs.
You know what I mean?
Like,
Oh yeah,
sure they do brother.
I'm sure they do,
right?
No doubt,
man.
No doubt.
Yeah,
they eat dogs.
Did you hear about a,
we were in Florida this weekend.
Fort Lauderdale.
I mean Dunkin had a great fucking time.
Awesome crowds.
Thank you.
Everybody who came out,
we had a fucking blast.
Um,
but when we were down there,
a dog had gotten eaten in the Florida keys recently by a crocodile.
A crocodile took a 65 pound Labrador.
It flew four feet out of the water and snatched it off of like a wall.
They're probably happens on,
my dog was barking.
There's dogs bark.
I don't know man.
I don't think,
I think this is pretty rare.
It's a big dog.
See,
crocodiles are so much more dangerous.
They go after shit.
That's what people don't understand.
Like in Florida,
like when,
when I was a kid,
I lived in Gainesville and we would feed the alligators marshmallows and shit
and they would like ask you to please don't feed the alligators.
Marshmallows cause marshmallows getting their digestive tract.
Meanwhile these alligators would kill people's dogs.
They're like would kill like old ladies dogs.
I was there when it happened once.
It was like either it happened like right before we were there or right after we
were there.
But like my parents were really freaked out that an alligator eight fucking
lady's dog,
like she was walking along by the water and the thing just came out and snatch a
dog from her.
But crocodiles will chase people,
crocodiles will chase you.
They go after shit.
They're way more aggressive.
It's a completely different animal.
Alligators sit and they'll just sit and wait for something to fuck up so that,
that dog must have fucked up.
That dog just got too close.
But crocodile chase how fucking dog and might just jack the Old Lady,
you know they people no
problem.
And this one flew four feet in the air to kill a dog.
It's amazing that people would want to keep those around like they like you
can't even shoot them.
They have to,
they're protected.
What you,
you don't think that's dangerous when don't you guys have kids?
You want to keep this fucking still,
it's not like crocodiles are gonna go extinct.
If you want them,
go to Africa,
go fucking go look at them real quick and then come back home.
But let's,
let's kill all the crocodiles we have here.
He crazy.
Let's make belts out of those bitches.
Fuck Crocodiles Ecos you talking about we are fucking up the Florida ecosystem
though.
They got a real problem man with python.
So those stupid fucks release pythons and they get too big and then the fucking
everglades is like infested with giant pythons.
Dude.
We flew over the everglades and when we landed it was early in the morning.
Not,
not really,
you know,
like nine,
9:00 AM.
And as we're flying in,
um,
like looking out like how over the window,
it's beautiful,
but the fucking everglades are you,
it's just all swamp.
Like a big part of Florida is all just like water and trees growing out of the
water and fucking giant snakes,
giant 20 foot long pythons that are eaten alligators,
they're so big,
they're eating alligators.
There's a photo of a fucking python with an algae to burst out of it's stomach.
That's how basically the everglades or like the Amazon,
well it's kind of scarier than the Amazon cause it's almost all water.
Like a lot of it is water.
It's like where we were flying over,
it's like swampy and it's almost creepier than the Amazon cause like,
I don't know man.
They're both fucked up.
I guess the Amazon probably has more poisonous shit.
Would you go to the Amazon?
I'll go to the everglades before I'd go to that.
Cause I know a lot of the good old boys from Florida,
they'll fuck around and the everglades,
they get those boats with the,
uh,
like the fan behind it and they fish in the everglades.
I'm totally fascinated with looking at Amazon DVDs and documentaries about the
Amazon,
but I have no desire to ever go like swimming the rivers and shit like that.
I'm so not a jungle guy.
You remember when I first got this house and we sat in that I got to look a
little theater room and we watched that.
The documentaries from the BBC on the Amazon where you see that fucking crazy
bird eat that like ancient customer fish out of the Congo.
We talked about this before.
Yeah,
I mean remember what an impact that video had on you.
We just think about how ridiculous it would be to go to any sort of a rain
forest,
Congo,
the Amazon just to be dropped off in that shit and the Congo is the craziest.
Definitely people live in the Amazon.
I don't think there's a whole lot of people living in the everglades.
Well,
I think there's probably like some parts of the everglades we could drive to and
live in,
but it looked to me like there was a lot of it that will look like pretty God
damn wild.
Everyone just talking out of my ass.
Maybe people are just,
I think people,
there's a lot of people that live around there.
Isn't there a show like on swampy?
Yeah,
something like that.
People kept wanting to get me to go there though.
A lot of people I met were like,
dude,
you gotta come out of the fucking everglades with his man when?
When we party out there,
do we need some fucking mushrooms?
What's scary is people that live in deserts,
hilarious party in Florida.
Dude,
Florida parties hard.
They fucking party hard.
Those were the wild crowds.
I told him,
and this is true,
there's like the perfect crowd to get me ready for next week or for this week
now.
What'd you just modern now?
Yeah,
just did the Improv and Fort Lauderdale and just fuck it was fun,
man.
Great crowds,
but they're so wild.
It's crazy,
man.
It's like two out of three shows.
A girl would stand up and say some crazy shit.
It was.
It was a bunch of like really wild heckler experiences,
but they're fun.
They're really nice people,
man.
It was a good time.
Good God damn time.
But they live in a tropical country,
man,
Florida.
That's a goddamn tropical country.
South Florida,
you know this key.
This is the keys where the dog had eaten by the crocodile.
That's really like a tropical country.
I mean that's like,
those are like,
you got to drive to them over like a bridge,
you know,
those are,
that's a,
that's not even really connected.
I just got back from the desert and it was really weird singing about the people
that lived in the desert,
like the roads were not mean maintained.
So you just go through these like dirt roads and it looked like every single
person that's a hoarder.
Uh,
the rich hoarders get to come out here because that's,
every house seemed like a hoarder house from just the outside.
And there was parts where I,
I couldn't go cause there was like these dogs,
I would come into the street and like block you and they just wouldn't leave.
Like you couldn't drive through them.
It was fucking weird.
Man.
That desert is weird.
Well,
part of the desert.
You're talking about a Joshua tree.
Yeah,
but Dunkin's always trying to get me to go to Joshua tree.
There's this is,
you might be trying to rain man.
Yeah,
he might be.
But actually there's this place that we uh,
went to that was really,
really cool nurse like these 12 aero stream trailers and each one of these
trailers are,
have been remodeled and gut it out.
Like I stayed in the seventies one of my friends stayed in the like one that was
like all like eighties 80 like 1980s type shit.
And they have a,
you know,
archery shooting guns and they have one of those big tps where you go in there
and do drugs and stuff.
And like even on the book it's like people are like,
you know,
how did they sign?
Like,
hey had a great time.
You know,
they have like a book that you can sign and every one of these trailers.
And everyone was like,
dude had the best shroom trip ever.
Like I'm tripping my ass off right now.
This is what my mom looks like.
They just drawing pictures and the whole place seemed bad ass.
And I thought,
how cool would it be to rent out every single one of these trailers and just
have like a big party with all your friends because that's what it was.
It was designed for you just to go there and experience psychedelics and just,
it was Josh,
which it was designed for that,
that,
this place to say that there's a lot of that up there.
Right.
It's so amazing.
There's so many different places like that,
but I heard of it and I used to go to Joshua tree as a kid all the time with the
boy scouts.
Used to go all the time.
Yeah.
And,
but never on money.
Let you,
uh,
I brought my dogs.
And can you go in that big room and sing?
You can do whatever the fuck you want,
man.
It's,
it's designed for you and eat.
The biggest thing is,
and made me really realize that I could live in one of those arrows streams if I
want.
I can almost live.
They're like,
those are so nice.
How big they are.
Do you have internet?
Yeah.
Had Internet.
We had,
we had a hot tub pools,
ping pong table live in something like that.
My,
my friend Guido that I was talking about earlier and he lives in like a big
mobile mobile home phone,
Internet.
Would you still do it without an internet?
Fuck that.
Okay.
But that's cool because you can move your wherever you want to live.
Like I know that Malibu has this really nice place that you can just park your
aero stream in,
like rent the spot per month.
And I forget what,
uh,
what's his name?
The guy from oh right.
Oh right.
That guy was the girls keep getting younger and I keep on saying the same age.
What's that guy's name?
Matt mcconahey.
Matt mcconaughey.
He rented a place in Malibu where he had his trailers and oh yeah.
Didn't mean like live in a trailer for a while.
Well done movie star.
I think he still does.
She not,
I don't think so.
Mad He's married now.
He's going to,
he had a little cameo in the season finale of eastbound and down.
Oh my God.
I saw that his cameo was on,
let's can we talk about the economy killed it.
That was his best prophase.
Brilliant.
I Saint Matthew Ma Mikaila is great.
Tropic Thunder.
He was great.
Exactly.
He's creating everything.
He's got this like,
he was great.
He wasn't in that one way.
Wouldn't it be great to smoke weed with him?
I was going to say he was great in that dragon movie,
but he wasn't in that dragon movie trouble or he killed.
I was,
for whatever reason,
I thought he was in that Christian Bale movie about dragons,
but it wasn't
dragging movie.
You don't kill it.
I saw that hunger games,
the hunger games now.
I haven't seen it yet.
Woody Harrelson.
He's a bad motherfucker.
Was it good?
It's not a bad moving.
It's a,
it's,
you know,
it's kind of a,
it's kind of fun.
You know,
cabin in the woods.
The worst garbage ever way.
That was good that somebody just told me to see that.
Oh God.
What's it about?
It's terrible.
What is it about,
what is it about a cabin in the woods,
right?
Yeah.
Maybe is about it.
Is it like it's way worse than you can imagine.
Describe it.
Do you want me to tell you about it?
Fuck you.
I don't want to blow it.
Don't
blow.
It really sucked.
You really feel like it's,
it's about,
it's about some God who has signing actual human scientists working for them to
sacrifice Virginians.
So the way the scientists get to sacrifice virgins is they,
they
got like CIA connections where they,
they,
they somehow coordinate three guys and two girls to take a trip out in the cabin
in the woods for a weekend and party.
And then while they're out there,
it's all experiment that's all like fenced off electronically.
So the scientists are all programming,
you know,
they think they're just going out to a cabin,
swimming in the lake.
But they're part of an expense,
a sacrifice.
And one of them is a virgin and they decide based on what they do,
there's like some magic books that they read in the cellar based on what they
re,
they decide how they're going to die.
Are they going to read,
are they going to have the zombies attack him?
Goes to attack them.
Girls with no face,
just a mouth attack them.
There's every giant cobras.
They're all in little boxes.
Every monster you could think of is in a little box under the lake and they,
based on what they read,
they did based on what they read.
They got the zombies that like a mountain men that were killed and now they're
zombies and they come out with after afterwards with horse traps and an access,
there's like three family and like the scientists are all betting it's a comedy.
The scientists are all betting.
There's like 20 sides.
They're all betting on how they're going to,
what monsters are they gonna release based on reading this magic book.
So you know there's $100 on the zombies.
They got the fucking giant Cobra,
they got the ghost,
they got the guy with the,
the saw head,
they've got all these,
they're all betting on all these monsters and goblins and ghouls.
Sounds like a movie you actually would like to dump.
Might be my favorite movie ever.
Just,
they're all working and guests who,
the main director is that th that that communicates with the Gods because they
want Sigourney weaver.
Yup.
That makes a cameo in the worst movie ever.
It was like,
it was like a Las Vegas appearance for something.
You know what I mean?
Jesus Christ.
Who was the seral celebrity apprentice hall.
Oh,
that's fun.
How's that possible that they got her?
I guess they must've just offered us a mad lute did she had some tax problems?
I think
she was just an Avatar man.
You didn't read the scratch.
She's from alien.
You know what?
They gave her another script.
I think that's one of those.
Maybe it's that we're going to disagree on like alien.
Fine.
It was just amazing.
Whoa,
whoa.
Hold on.
Wine.
Go Watch it.
It was a comedy.
It was.
It was a calm,
and I'm not even joking.
It wasn't,
comedy was hilarious.
How high were you saw it.
I was,
I was pretty high.
I had a glass of wine.
You know what I mean?
I was ready to enjoy this shit.
Right,
right.
It was really you.
You'd never been one for like fantasy type movies?
It was ridiculous.
I like,
I like a lot of ridiculous movies.
Yeah.
Like I like superhero
movies.
You like she'll be here on my list.
No,
no,
no.
See if I know the guy's going to live.
I don't want to see this shit.
Every superhero movies the same are seven or eight like moments where he's like
about to die and then he does,
you know he's not going to die.
Yeah,
I know.
It's a superhero movie that I'm not into that man.
I'm not doing it.
You see the watchman?
Yes I did.
It's a good superhero movie cause it's sort of an anti superhero movie.
Yeah,
that was pretty good.
First Superhero movie.
That was,
I was all right.
That was pretty out.
I'm just not,
it was a great room.
If there were,
if they're wearing tights and they got capes and they're flying and shit like
that,
that's hard for me.
Got Us like,
I don't know.
I know it could really happen,
but iron man was the shit dude.
He didn't like iron man.
That was cool because that could really happen.
Okay.
Because he's like a machine.
It's like a machine.
You know what I mean?
They made iron man.
It was cool cause it was believable to,
the guy made a nuclear reactor and stuck in his chest.
That shit ain't real fuck outta here.
Oh,
you're like iron man.
It's totally possible.
Batman's more possible that iron man.
I think iron man is more possible.
Iron man man is a regular human being.
Batman is just a super yoke.
Dude is like that.
A lifetime ago he would have been today or Lawsky when he was in his prime.
If Andre Arlovski was in his prime when he was,
he could have been a real lot of times.
Was He tied up and then at the last second he gets out
Bluefin.
Yeah.
It's much more positive and having a nuclear reactor for a heart and he's
reaching in and he's having a fucking,
what's her face?
Gwyneth Paltrow reach in there and pull the wires out.
That's preposterous.
And are they all sign fuck iron man.
I don't give a shit.
I want to know iron man t shirt.
I thought it was I,
I like Robert Downey jr you wouldn't wear an iron man.
I have a captain America t shirt.
I'm not into customer.
Correct.
I'm not in the common below.
I'm just don't read them very often man.
But I'll tell you what,
when I was a kid,
they brought me great joy when I was a kid and I was moving around.
We're moved around all over the country,
the constant in my life because like when we moved a bunch of times,
like it takes a while to make friends.
You're in one place and then you move in two years and you're another place.
Comic books were like my constant buddy when I was a young kid.
So to me like I'll always have like a special spot in my heart for comic books.
Cause I even remember the effect that they had on me when I was a kid.
And that's undeniable.
Like to say now that I'm over that or that's ridiculous.
No,
they're still cool.
They're still cool.
It's just there's other shit.
It's cooler for me to do with my time.
I really don't have that much time to devote to comic books,
but I still love him.
He did comic book story lately.
No,
but you know I have,
I really do like watching comics on my iPad.
I'll buy like the marvel comic series on my Ipad,
you know.
And um,
there's a there,
there are quite a few that you can you buy.
You'll be surprised how much you'll freak the fuck out.
Then if you go inside a comic book store,
I mean tee tee shirt wise,
toy wise comic,
why you'll go in there.
But holy cow,
look at this teacher.
Oh look this weird poster.
It's fun though is the way the iPad does it where it's frame by frame.
It's nice.
It's nice because it really is like it's better.
It's better to read a comic book on an Ipad than it is to,
to read it in the actual form because then the actual form,
you can see all the shit that's going to happen on the next page version and it
really ruins it.
But the IPAD,
it's dope.
Like you don't see explosions come and you don't see anything coming.
It's nice.
The only comics I was into,
tourism or the hustler comics.
I was really at that hospital,
had the best jokes,
like whoever was writing those jokes.
That was a good quality comic.
That's some funny shit.
Playboy was not as funny,
but hustler had some great shit.
I would design flyers like the bands I was in,
the speed metal bands I was in.
My thing was when you give out a flyer for your band,
people just throw it away and go,
how could I get them to keep it for a little bit?
I would design a flyer on top of a hustler,
a comic,
so I'm basically giving them a comic and they are looking at like some,
some dude,
there's one,
there's just one word there.
There's a do a doctor walking in with the check and the doctors telling the
chick,
we did what we could.
It was a really bad accident and they walk into the hospital and there's a dude
lane there.
It's just a head,
a Dick and a hand that I used that as a flyer ahead of ticking a hand.
Yeah,
there's a dude lion.
They're in the hospital bed.
He's just the head,
a Dick and a hand.
I thought that was the funniest shit ever.
And the doctor wanted the doctors walking in,
you know,
with this chick was like,
it was a horrible accident.
We did what we could.
Oh,
that's funny.
come on man.
That was hustling,
Bro.
We're allowed to have different tastes.
We obviously do.
We're best friends.
We don't even grow real comics.
I never,
I never got into a man.
I was way,
I was a big kiss fan.
They had kiss comics.
I didn't read the comics.
I didn't read them.
I don't know why I wasn't into it.
I think,
um,
you're,
you're just don't like obvious heroes.
And,
and I didn't like reading to begin with.
That's a big part of it.
I didn't read and the only thing I read was magazines,
like rock magazines.
I was totally into that.
Shark books,
dinosaur books,
a lot of books.
And I was a kid.
I wrote a lot.
Those great.
It was,
um,
that's how I got into college books.
I read a lot of shit when I was a kid.
You know,
like again,
if you don't have that many friends you're read.
And like when I was going to taekwondo for most of my life,
I would take the t in Boston,
so I'd have to walk to the train and take the training and it's like,
you know,
40 minutes or something like that.
I don't always read,
you know,
read,
get it,
get a Stephen King Book and when you really,
when you get into a good book,
man,
it's fucking really fun man.
A good Stephen King Book.
God Damn,
they're fun.
I never know.
Oh Dude.
I read half of it and then I was like,
I can't do it is an amazing book.
God,
that pet cemetery is a fucking great book.
The movie was fun,
but Goddamn that fucking book.
It's good,
it's fun.
He just knows how to drag you in and it's just entertainment,
man.
It's a lot of times.
To me,
I find it much more enjoyable than watching some terrible moving.
A terrible movie won't engage me at all if it's a great movie.
I would much rather prefer a great movie than to read a book.
But a lot of movies aren't movies.
A lot of
movies are an alien,
you know what I mean?
A lot of movies don't just fucking completely suck you in.
In that case.
Sometimes a book is way better than a shitty movie.
It's a way better experience.
Do you ever read his lot more great books?
Did you ever read a kings like dark tower or whatever that shits called?
Dunkin raves about that,
but those are daunting dude.
Those are thousands of pages long.
Like you look at the whole dark tower series.
Stephen King was up bad mother fucker.
You want to talk about it?
Dude?
It's put out a lot of work.
Holy Shit.
Is that guy prolific?
Who the hell writes more than Stephen King?
I mean,
that guy's always got a new book coming out.
He's got another one coming out right now and he's just constantly jams at it
and that he got fucked up by a car.
He got hit by a van.
Yeah,
like bad,
like broke bones all over his body.
Several years ago he got fucked up,
man.
It took a long time to rebuild them.
Many,
many surgeries.
He's an incredible pain for a long period of time.
And then they started writing again.
Got Right back into that shit.
I'd like to say a documentary on that guy,
like his childhood.
I wonder what it was like growing up.
Well,
he's got a great book.
It's called Stephen King on writing.
I think it's called was up.
I think that,
um,
and uh,
it's,
uh,
I think that's it.
Just look,
look up Stephen King's book on writing if you're interested in it,
but it's a great shows you like how pragmatic is thinking is,
and you know,
he's a very honest about what it was like when he was,
uh,
doing a lot of drinking and doing a lot of drugs that he would like black out
and not even remember a book that he wrote.
Like he's talked about several of his books.
He doesn't remember writing him cause he was just fucked up.
But they're brilliant books.
The Mat Indian in him carry.
That's him.
That's a great fucking book.
Oops.
Mower drive is the best movie back in it.
We'll just say he's the most famous writer.
He's gotta be one of them.
He's got to be one of the most famous writers like William Shakespeare.
Like who else?
Well,
I mean living for sure.
He's one of the most famous living.
Who else would be famous?
I mean,
you get into people like the woman who wrote Harry Potter.
She's probably really famous,
but Steve,
I don't know her name fucker.
I know who,
I know Harry Potter.
I know the name of the movies,
but I don't know the woman's name is Stephen King.
Like he's crazy fans.
Yeah.
As far as like thing,
he's probably the most easily recognizable name of a writer.
He's probably,
if I had to say he's my all time favorite fiction writer,
I would say yes.
I'd say he's number one.
The Michael Jackson,
the shit writing.
He's got so many.
The Tommy,
Tommy knockers.
Ooh,
I love that one.
That was a great one.
So fucking long.
A UFO crashed into this area like thousands of years ago and it started this.
Did they dig into it and reactivated or some shit and people get infected by
these Ufo shows and start changing?
I forget the exact plot of it,
but I remember just one of my favorites when I was a listening and I would like,
I'll be bummed out when my stop would come.
I wonder how he comes up with this shit.
Well He,
I'm sure he smokes a lot of weed because he talks about,
it talks about how great the,
the weed is and Maine and how it should be
a cottage industry and the,
you know,
the weed laws are ridiculous.
A lot of writers use weed,
you know,
I mean,
we know that,
how many writers do we know that are just fiction writers guys are run on
sitcoms.
Guys who write movie La Writers use weed.
So of course I'm sure he uses weed.
Jason Ellis has a new book and it's came out today I think.
And he was on some interview earlier and he was talking about like how he's a
cutter and like he has this new thing where he,
like,
he meets this girl and,
and,
and they cut each other and they just suck each other's blood.
And,
and so he was talking about going on this book tour,
like hitting me like he's like,
he's going to cut himself and then like,
like stamp,
you know,
instead of signing it,
he's going to start stamping it with this be show crazy.
That dude is that dude like the whole interview,
I think it was Howard Stern.
The whole interview was so fucking creepy.
I feel bad for that guy.
He's an odd guy.
Whoa.
His Dad's sucked his dick and then you had to suck his dad's Dick was,
yeah,
when he was like six.
Hello?
Yeah.
No,
I don't think so.
Yeah.
It was all in this interview man and
Jason Ellis.
Damn.
Wow,
that explains wow.
Well No,
no it doesn't explain cause he's a lot more together then 99.99999999% of the
world.
Who would have had that same experience happen to them?
He's very successful guy.
A lot of people who have had that same experience would probably be wrecked.
And he's sober,
isn't he?
Yeah,
he doesn't drink.
He smokes a little,
well,
I don't know.
I think he's actually sober.
Yeah.
I now he's completely sober.
I don't know though.
I'd have to,
I haven't done a show in a while and I'm not upset at that dude.
He drinks some upset at him because he a prank call me once I changed my number
but I wasn't upset.
I just automatically change my number of someone that gets it and starts prank
calling me and I just,
I did it automatically.
I wasn't upset at it.
I thought it was,
I was like,
oh,
okay.
Whatever.
I didn't think it was like particularly on your number.
No,
no,
no.
He prank called me.
He's friend called me and said some horrible Boston accent or stuff like that
and he did it on the air.
It was a good and well,
well cause I like him.
I would've said it was funny.
If I knew it was him I would,
I would think it's funny cause I like him but not,
wasn't that particularly funny?
He does.
You know,
but I didn't,
I didn't get upset.
I just changed my number.
He also talked about going to Amsterdam and getting a hooker and how it was a
trainee and he started getting something shoved up his ass like a dildo.
And he was like,
no,
I don't,
I don't want that.
And it was actually a cock of the tranny.
He didn't know it was a trainee or Jesus Christ Jesus.
Wow.
A tranny hooker function in the ass a little bit.
But he didn't want his book.
The style of like he just told somebody and they wrote it down.
Oh yeah.
And he hasn't even read it yet.
Miss Thailand at 2010 or something like that is a training.
Yeah,
still louder in de Miss Universe or whatever.
Crazy book has a password.
So Miss World,
what does it mean guys?
Talk about on the podcast writing?
No,
well we showed pictures over man.
It's incredible.
She's really hot.
It's weird.
I they get the boys
early before they testosterone kicks in and they get them on hormone therapy.
Is that what it is?
Yup.
That's what they do with her.
I don't know if they did with her,
but apparently this is what I hear.
I could be totally wrong,
but in some Asian countries they'll take a a dude and get them on female
hormones quick to make the money back to survive.
Like you're going to be a check now and you're going to be a hooker.
There's one fucking story of these two lesbians that had the son,
I don't know if it was a natural birth son or an adopted son,
I'm not sure.
But uh,
they had a son and I believe the kid was 10 and they wanted to get the kid ready
for age,
gender reassignment.
Cause they said that the boy actually was saying that he was a girl.
Okay.
That's probably what they wanted him to wear dresses.
They,
you know,
he would dress up like a girl and they were like,
he's getting ready to become a girl.
And everybody's like,
Whoa,
you don't see the problem with this.
You don't,
Whoa does this does not give you a gigantic green light here for crazy.
That's,
that's the crazy express is wide open.
This person is saying that a 10 year old once a gender reassignment Jesus
fucking Christ really,
you don't even know none of that is,
I bet that's just normal.
What is the that Kid's life like?
What is that Kid's environment let to make money?
But I mean,
that's like that,
that it's one of those things that you would think that someone would make up on
like some extreme crazy right wing site because it would make conservative
people so fucking furious.
You know,
the,
this could happen that someone could have,
you know,
uh,
this,
this boy and at 10 years old be setting him up for gender reassignment and what
a fucking travesty that it is and what it does.
Like,
it's almost like an obvious attack on the gender itself.
It's like he doesn't want to be this anymore.
He wants to be another thing like us.
He wants to be like mommy and mommy.
Yeah.
You know?
Whoa.
Could you imagine if you had to stick with the rest of your life with fucking
decisions?
You made it 10.
Holy Fuck Dude.
Being a,
being a transgender is totally normal in Thailand.
They accept that they're celebrities that are transgenders are transvestites,
whatever you want to call,
it's totally normal.
It's amazing.
Be accepted.
I wonder how that happened.
How crazy is that?
I wonder how that happened now.
Okay,
no shit.
Yeah,
someone was a,
there was an article I think on the underground talking about,
uh,
how lady boys will fuck dudes up if dudes,
you know,
like,
some guys get like real disrespectful with lady boys.
They don't realize that that's still a man and still a man and he probably knows
how to punch in a fuck you up man.
Like the stories about them getting upset.
Well,
you know,
you saw a Guy Jujitsu who had the body of a 13 year old Thai girl.
I could be like,
there's no way you're going to do shit on the fuck you up.
I don't care.
I don't care if you were born with balls.
You know,
they're so frail and tiny.
They are frail and tiny.
But the reality is if you,
if you're like a a girl and you weigh like 130 plus pounds,
there's a few girls that are around that weight that can punch in the face and
knock you unconscious.
Legit.
Like my friend Tommy Jr.
Did you ever meet my friend Tommy Junior?
You met my friend Tommy Junior from Connecticut.
He met,
I believe you met him at UFC before.
Anyway,
his girl has a ridiculously powerful punch.
The ridiculous,
yeah,
ridiculous.
She sets up one of those,
those things like at the bar when you know,
when you put in a quarter and you fucking smash that punching bag,
dude,
she,
she hits harder than guys on that thing.
If she soccer punched you,
you're fucked.
So if that was a tie check,
if she was,
it was a tie check that could punch like she punches and you know,
you thought you were an asshole.
You know,
you're gonna just going to fucking push her around.
You're drunk and she just uncorked one on your chin and your legs give out full
level and pull and then she fucking shame kicks you in the face again.
That's all real man.
A girl,
135 pound athletic girl.
It's very possible for that check to kick your ass if you don't know what you're
doing.
That's what I say when you get to,
when I look at a girl like Tommy Junior's girlfriend,
I say,
okay,
if she wanted to,
if you didn't know what you were doing and she uncorked a couple on you before
you knew it was happening,
you could get knocked the fuck out for real.
So that's like,
that's like the size that you have to be,
I think to be able to survive against the average size human,
at least 135 pound woman.
Yeah.
So if you're hunting 10 pounds,
you need to get on roids.
Yeah.
Damn cabin in the woods on him for the [inaudible] 92% Oh shit.
I think Eddie,
Eddie Bravo 92 and the guy that on rotten tomatoes.
Why do I have a feeling this is going to be like my favorite movie of all time
because it sounds awesome.
And the guy who wrote cabin in the woods is also the director of the new
adventures.
Maybe so you know,
I might go to go see cabin in the woods tonight.
Well I didn't say the directing was bad.
It was terrible.
Whoever wrote it made that story.
Oh,
he wrote it.
Yeah.
Damn.
I'm sorry.
I should've lied.
Well listen man,
I know you have very specific tastes.
Super specific taste when it comes to movies you don't like reading was last
Werewolf movie you enjoyed.
I'm not done with the world.
Did you ever see the movie cake liken a underworld thing.
That's,
that's it's cool to watch because of the colors and stuff and I had to kick ass.
Kick ass was awesome.
It was great.
I love kicking.
That was a great fucking,
I can't wait for the sequel.
When is that coming out?
Yeah,
that was a,
that was a great fucking ass.
It's great.
Yeah.
You,
you never did you see American Werewolf in London?
Yes,
but I think I was eight.
The Werewolf was that this convention the other day in Burbank,
the guy played the Werewolf.
Oh,
more convention.
What is his name?
I don't remember.
Yeah,
that dude was in a couple of movies.
He was like a star for a little bit.
There's dudes like that that become like a star for a little bit.
Who we should respect back
to that car.
Cause that's what CACTI.
MMM.
Um,
I don't remember his fucking name.
John Land.
David Naughton.
That's his name.
God.
Damn,
that thing was awesome.
Look at that shit dude.
Yeah.
That's cool.
Oh,
that thing's amazing.
What the fuck?
What a crazy monster that werewolf laws.
Those are just fun movies for me,
man.
[inaudible] some people they like movies that are sad and realistic where the,
the good guy dies.
Me,
I'm not really into that.
I just want to be entertained.
I just want you to take me on a trip.
It could be PR.
No one has to die.
I'm not saying make it unpredictable.
Right.
What's your,
what's your like all time favorite movie?
Do you have an all time favorite?
Gleaming the Cube Bra.
I mean there's all the classics,
you know,
aliens.
Part two was one of my all time favorites.
I liked her a lot.
Did you like the first one,
you know,
in scar face of course and uh,
Goodfellas and Casino and Godfather.
Did you like the first alien?
Yes.
First I liked the second alien better,
but the first alien was also really good alien three soc.
I didn't like it.
I didn't mind it.
I didn't mind the through one of the funniest,
most misunderstood movies ever for me.
And most people thought it was just total shit.
Was Freddy got fingered.
That's still one of my all time favorites are.
I love that movie man.
Star Wars.
Did you like fighting off Tinder?
Yeah.
Isn't it great?
What's your favorite star wars movie?
Which is the,
the,
the Labor scene when he gave a,
when he had gave birth to that baby,
that was,
it's the greatest thing ever.
What was your question?
I'm sorry.
What's your favorite star wars?
Did you like start really into star wars?
A little bit.
You know,
like empire strikes back.
That was a classic and Shit.
Yoda.
He was cool.
I'm not like,
like episode one and all that new shit.
They lost me.
You lost me with that.
Well,
I think it's funny though,
but I know,
uh,
I think it has to do with like your,
your past.
Like you don't,
you not into like anybody lying to you.
You don't want any bullshit,
man.
You know,
I don't want any holes in the story.
You don't want anybody like about to go over the cliff and digs the hammer into
the side of the hill and sage theirself dangling over the fucking side of the
cliff holding onto it.
I love will Ferrell movies like fucking stepbrothers.
I could watch that over and over,
overstepping me.
One of the greatest movies ever.
Talladega nights.
Tropic Thunder.
That's probably top three greatest comedies ever,
if not the funniest one.
Tropic Thunder.
Probably the funniest fucking movie all the way through.
Every character was played an asshole in a movie and they were all brilliant.
And uh,
I like that shit.
You know,
obviously I'm just not into superheroes stuff.
Well,
the watchman will be for my son.
You know,
I probably will.
I'll probably get into it and be forced to like lords of the rings and Shit like
that
dude,
that actually puts me
to fucking dragons are fine and then the ghost winning the ghost end of
fighting.
There's just like constant the movies with the constant Braveheart clashing or
they're just like fucking just swinging at each other.
I see.
Braveheart is the only one I could watch like that.
All the other ones forget about it.
There's who fights like that?
I'd be running the other fucking way.
Just going to come in with fucking swords.
Fuck that shit.
Grabbed my kids and get the fuck out.
I think that's how they rocked it occasionally.
I don't think they did it that often though.
They did do that crazy.
I think a lot of it was sneaking up on bitches can get a lot of war was back
then.
It's just like you had to convince them.
That was the Jesus man.
You got to convince them you're doing this for Jesus.
You're doing this for God.
Like the Keester doors and all that shit.
Without Jesus,
they wouldn't have been able to pull that shit really,
but they were just raping and getting Indian pussy all over the world.
How do you get Indian pussy all over the world?
You have to bring it with you.
They thought they were doing God's mission,
man.
They thought they were saving them.
Maybe.
Maybe they were having a good fucking time to that.
That's possible.
Raping and pillaging with swords.
This game of Thrones movie shows,
so God damn addicted and that's what it's all about.
Everybody just falls short.
I heard it's like there's a lot of characters and you just kind of,
there's some points where you're just like,
all right,
there's just too much.
I can't say because I'm only on five episodes,
but as of five episodes,
there's a couple moments where you got to go,
okay,
that guy's a mad.
The mad king.
Okay.
And he did that and it was just,
Oh,
okay.
I see what happened there.
Is this kind of like the tutors also where it's geared towards women and some
weird romantic sex way?
No,
no,
no.
I don't think so.
It's fucking cruel.
Too cruel.
Show and a lot of titties and a lot of fucking it.
A lot of prostitution,
a lot of betrayal.
Good Times.
Some incest.
It's a crazy fucking show.
It could not have existed outside HBO.
Oh yeah.
Hot Brother and sister.
What?
She had illegal back in the day.
No,
it wasn't necessarily normal.
I don't want to give away any spoilers,
but I figured it out.
According to mainstream Egyptology Pharaohs would like all their sisters and all
their relatives where their wives that had hundreds of them according to Egypt,
tall,
mainstream,
Egyptology.
That's not it,
but I don't know anything.
But I think a lot of times royal families,
we're trying to keep their bloodlines pure.
Right?
They were trying to only marry with,
there are some shit to that blood line,
man.
There's,
there's some shit.
They were fucking their own daughters to that bloodline.
That bloodline was so important.
They're like,
fuck it.
You're all staying in.
We're going to keep this in the family.
Well,
could you imagine the discrepancy too,
between being a king and being a peasant back then and really there's nothing
you did earn that position.
You're just royal family.
You're the son of the son of this fucking guy has been ruling his kingdom
forever and you just rise.
Yeah,
man,
it's gotta be crazy shit.
We were,
uh,
you know,
just think about what it is,
the difference between the guy who was at the very top and the guy was at the
very bottom and why?
Because he's got royal blood and that's crazy.
There.
I forget the title,
but this woman had the title.
She was the wife that was in charge of organizing who is going to hang out with
the feral.
She was like the event coordinator who's also not that crazy,
ridiculous,
ridiculous.
Damn God.
Damn.
I think the way that people have always rocked it throughout history is there've
been just wild freak fuck festivals to just people just fuck all over the place.
Dude have that.
I think that's one of the things is game of Thrones thing is so accurate.
I think people just put people back in those days,
they only lived,
you know,
they're going to get hacked to death by a fucking guy with a sword that
someone's going to get them.
They're going to,
someone's going to betray or something.
They're trying to get the freak on every step of the way.
She's Kama Sutra wild back then,
man.
It's amazing when you really think about like the amount of time that went
between then and now.
That's not that much time.
If you really stop and think about it,
you know?
Well,
ancient religions,
the ancient Chinese and the the Hindus,
they all believed that having sex got you closer to God and it was.
That's how you got close.
It was almost like meditation saw they had back then they didn't have TV.
That's all they had.
They thought sex brought you closer to God because he didn't have the Internet.
Yeah,
it feels great.
Of course it feels great.
That's the big Trekkie dummy.
That's why you make people,
the universe is created.
All your spirituality just went down.
The tubes are like,
fuck that.
I'm like,
are you turn it on and off?
It's funny.
Fuck it.
You're going to crush spirituality,
but you're a spiritual person,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
I'm certainly a nice person for sure.
Would you consider yourself a spiritual person?
I don't like that word,
but um,
because I feel like it has too many weirdo connotations.
I would definitely say I tried to be a very positive person.
I try to be really nice to people.
I try,
I go out of my way to do that.
I go on any kind of spirituality involved in that.
I think there's an,
there's whatever you would want to call it.
There's certainly an exchange in,
um,
in,
in energy and in an,
in an enhancement of each other that I feel like we,
like we all have,
we all have as friends,
you know,
everyone in this room.
I'm Brian.
I for sure.
I mean,
I've known Brian for a decade.
We enhance each other for sure.
I mean,
that's one of the reasons why they call it and I enjoy doing the podcast with
him.
Man.
I know gay jokes,
Bro.
You and I,
man,
we enhance each other.
You mean for,
you know,
we've always enjoyed having these crazy conversations even if we don't agree
about a lot of shit and we don't agree about a lot of shit,
but we've always enjoyed it.
Because I favor,
I favor your opinion over everyone else's and treated equally as if it was mine.
Because I know you so well.
I know how your mind works.
So every time you have an opinion on something I accepted as if it's me having
that opinion,
I allow myself
to go through the whole process.
This is not a whole lot of people that you can do that with in life.
You know?
There's not a whole lot of people where you go,
yeah,
Bob said he didn't do anything,
but it's fucking fingerprints are everywhere.
And the murder weapon was in the street in front of us mind,
you know?
You know what I mean?
There's few dudes where you,
you,
you always know where they're coming from.
You know,
and I think having people like that in your life is that it's one of the most
important things.
It's,
it's,
it's like more important than what you do for a living mo.
The most important thing is you've got to cultivate great friendships because
then once you cultivate great friendships,
you each get better at everything else while you're involved in a friendship
with someone who's also getting better.
You know,
I think my comedy right now has never,
I've never felt better about it and one of the things that I feel really good
about it is that I hear Ari is fucking killing it on the road.
I hear already,
like packed it in Vancouver and fucking crush he's got,
he's headlined in all these places that I do.
You know,
like he's headlining big places.
It's just doing the comedy works in Denver and that's,
I don't care that it's awesome.
I Take Duncan on the road of me,
he goes on stage,
he gets standing ovations.
Dude,
when we were in Louisville,
Dunkin got standing ovations every time just walking on stage.
They're going nuts and cheering.
That makes me feel better about comedy than anything.
Like there's a trick to life and a big part of it is generosity is a big part of
it is appreciation for other people's success.
A big part of it is being around other people that are trying to go for success
and enhancing each other along the way.
You know,
having a group of people that are all doing positive shit and move forward and
being,
you know,
doing what they want to do man and having it all come together like everybody
together doing that together.
That's all like a big juicy enhancement.
Like Joey Dee has just got number one on iTunes.
He said number one comedy CD on iTunes.
Dude Dude,
he called me up.
He goes,
Joe Rogan,
I just want to thank you very much for doing this with fucking knock them dead.
That's just beginning when laying bitches out.
He was going crazy.
It was full on fire it up full on,
fire it up.
He was on a hundred percent Joey Diaz.
I thought he was so excited.
Yeah,
but I mean how,
how could that have ever happened before?
He has his podcast,
his podcast,
a beauty and the beast.
People love that fucking podcast.
Dunkin's podcast is,
he's killing it on that podcast.
People love the Dunkin's new podcast,
always pockets and all of that shit happens.
It builds us all up.
It helps us all.
You need to start a podcast,
dude,
for sure.
You need to do a podcast.
I,
it's just,
it's easy dudes.
I Dunno man.
You got time.
You should.
You should seriously consider it because I think it would,
it would blow your fucking seminars through the roof.
It would be a way where you could instantly talk to people,
address questions.
It's hard,
man.
You know I got the baby just came.
Oh,
I hear you brother.
I mean,
you don't have to do it right away,
but start thinking about it and then when you get to a position where you get
just a couple of free hours a week,
you know what you think you might be able to devote to that slide
on in your thing will be a hit right off the bat.
Dude,
I'm going to do this.
Podcast is 14 year old kid does his own podcast and he does it all on kiss every
he got into Kinzie's 14 and 2008 that's when I got into because in 1978 and he's
a kiss fucking maniac.
I'm going to do as podcasts like in a week.
And I heard one of his podcasts and he's like a little genius.
He's 14 years old running the show.
He's the host.
He's like a little baby Howard Stern.
You didn't meet him at Clark?
Did you know?
I met him through Twitter and then you know,
he gave me,
she has a van.
But yeah.
But I,
you know,
I think about it every now and then,
but I,
I don't mind the way my life is right now,
you know,
just to add like I hear what you're saying.
I like my life the way it is and if I added a show then I'd be forced to talk
all the time.
I like just being a guest every now and then.
I like it like then and everything stays fresh.
I Dunno about like trying to keep it together.
I'm going to be involved.
You think you know a bloody Twitter war tonight with pro nine 11 people.
I love those guys.
Those guys are awesome.
The building was on fire.
It was proven.
Look,
look,
here's the link.
It was on fire.
Like those guys are hilarious.
There's a lot of smart people and that's hard.
There's a lot of smart people that don't think that it was an inside job.
Aye,
look,
Aye.
I reserve my right to not form an opinion on that and I just look at all of it
and I go,
yeah,
there's certainly some fuckery afoot that Donald Rumsfeld thing is crazy.
That's really crossed.
Not even tower seven.
I mean how amazingly coincidental adjustive that happened alone.
If that happened without the towers,
you would be like,
wait a minute,
what?
But because the towers went down to,
it was almost like there's so much chaos in one day.
They got away with that depth Pentagon.
Perfect.
It's really,
if you want him to steal $2 trillion in money,
if they're really did steal that much money,
I mean,
wow.
Would that not be the greatest jacking in the history of humanity?
If they really did pull that off and all of that was just designed to cover up
their jacking of the of the records in the Pentagon and then they said,
well,
you know what,
while we're at it,
let's just go to war with Iraq and take their shit.
Boom.
I get these big diff,
I mean if they just decided like we got this dude,
everybody is on our side or just American flags everywhere.
Let's just run with this shit.
Let's run with it,
and they just ran with it.
There's just storm troopin taking money on CNN.
Oh man,
this is real.
This is really happening with real people and real bullets in 2012 scary shit,
man.
It's amazing Gary.
Like how do you trust a government like that?
How do you,
how does Obama become that guy?
He's like,
oh,
only a few years older than me.
That freaks me out.
How does a guy who grew up essentially in the same area as me and who grew up
around a lot of like leftists and a lot of like,
you know,
like he grew up around like he knew some dude with that.
It was,
it was her professor who was from the weather underground.
That radical group.
Obama's part.
Yeah,
Obama's perfect.
Think about it,
George W.
Bush fucked up so hard.
The only way that we're going to keep the power of the people we're about to
fucking say,
fuck this revolution.
Let's give him Obama calm him down.
That was perfect.
We'll throw,
we'll fucking take all this shit and we'll drop Obama on them
buying another eight years.
Maybe another longer.
Dude that was up there.
It was all perfect and the Kootenai Obama run against a dude who was almost dead
and some crazy check.
It was perfect.
It really is worth it.
Whoever was putting this together and probably laughing and the writing probably
fucking bus.
Whose idea was Sarah Pailin?
That dude probably got like $1 million,
a dollar bonus from some Illuminati guy.
You know,
she,
she probably could win.
If there was a a sensible,
a person who was a real powerful Republican and he was the president and he
wanted her as a vice president at this point in time,
she might actually be able to get in.
She's become such a public celebrity and there's enough stupid people out there
that don't even see what's going on.
They're just flowing right with it and if they could just coach her,
if she would take some coaching,
apparently she's not in a good to take coaching,
which is one of the problems with her and they had on the car,
it should be.
She became a maverick yourself there on her own getting crazy,
telling the people what she really thinks.
She became a celebrity ticketless man,
this is insane,
this beautiful.
It's a movie.
It's like,
you know,
it really supports the theory that we're living inside some sort of a computer
generated reality when the more preposterous things happen,
that's ridiculous.
The more silly things happen in the news like that,
the more just ridiculous scenarios play out over and over again.
The more you got to just question like could you imagine if it really does turn
out that this whole thing is bullshit and you wake up one day and you and your
friends just uh,
he had shot up with some weird electronic drug that takes you on some 40 year
journey and then brings you back cause other dimension yeah,
brings you back and to you it was only a few minutes of time and that's your
whole life man.
Anything's possible.
Now could you imagine how weird that would be?
Anything in life was a series of,
of of re expanding and contracting little existences like that to take place and
the full lifetime inside of torn.
It's you're born with only two skills only to fucking screaming and you're,
the sucking muscles in your mouth are so developed.
You're,
you're born,
you have no control it fucking head.
You know,
what the hell are you doing with your arm?
Your muscles are nowhere near being develop.
Your legs are just kind of flopping around.
But though sucking muscles fully developed,
the vocal cords develop.
You would think of baby would come out with vocal cords
and they couldn't scream it.
How the fuck are they screaming?
So goddamn now that's developed shit.
It's like you come in to powers,
right?
You come in,
okay,
you're going to get sucking.
Everyone comes in with just sucking and scream screaming.
That's it.
Can't feed yourself.
Some days I'm a go in,
no fucking sucking,
no screaming.
I want to figure this shadow them.
I know do.
It's dangerous,
Bro.
It's dangerous.
Yet is any baby were combined and go sup,
Sup,
I'm here.
Yeah,
I mean are there they,
you know,
there's a,
I don't know if you call it a movement or or what it is,
but there's people out there that believe in indigo children.
You know what this is and you do it.
No,
supposedly it's,
this is like some crazy new age shit that there are children that are born
nowadays that are super smart,
like right when they're born.
I can,
they're super enlightened and I don't this,
this is probably all bullshit,
but if you go on youtube type in indigo children and they're like super
brilliant enlightened kit and caught autistic.
I Dunno,
maybe,
maybe it's a form of art to me,
a little bit of that,
right?
Maybe.
Maybe,
I don't know,
but
I've never met a a genius autistic kid.
Have you crazy.
I think that they all are most like,
like if you look at any of these movies,
like you know,
definitely whopping are definitely Washington,
but they always have like this memory,
you know,
where they can remember a thousand things.
They're almost like on it.
But if they're a step past us and they're,
they're just not until the gossip and bullshit of normal day lies.
But you had their fucking figuring out.
Right.
You know?
Well,
you know,
at a certain point in time the question becomes like,
what is is all of our emotions and all of our caveman ideas and genetics is all
that really going to be effective?
Do we need all these crazy emotions?
Do we need all this,
this,
this weird way of interacting with each other after a while.
Can that become something else?
And it could become something that's maybe more effective mathematically and
something that's maybe just not,
not as inclined to be swayed by emotion.
You know,
that it's just like a little detached,
a little detached from the human experience,
but much more elevated in a certain way.
I mean,
we've,
we look at it like it's a disease,
but on some of them maybe it's not,
you know,
look at like,
look at the language,
look how we're texting back and forth.
I like Twitter and we're not even using real words anymore.
This and 20 years is autism.
Yeah,
that's a really good point because if you,
if you think about how much is lost in a text message,
man,
the only people that I like texting with or people that I'm already close with
because then,
you know,
I could,
uh,
you know,
if you text me,
where are you at and saw your mother's supposed to,
you know,
you can,
we laugh at each other.
You know what I mean?
You could joke around.
We're all going to be autistic holograms in the future.
That is really possible.
We're going to be like two pocket Coachella Tupac look like you've been doing
MMA.
Like maybe he's been training with pop,
maybe he's been doing,
which is a strength and conditioning routine cause he looked yoked in 1980 and
1980 his clothes were all like just cheesy old nineties clothes or eighties
how did they do that?
Did they use actual footage of him and just make holograms of that or I don't
know,
$10 million.
How long this Coachella been around for?
Wow.
I was,
that's where 15 years was to talk live when Coachella was around.
Did he ever play a Coachella?
I'm not sure.
Well this,
this Tupac was saying what sub?
Coachella.
So put the back.
I think the whole thing was an act or whole thing is like a fake Tupac.
Yeah.
That was the CGI and that was someone else's voice.
Ooh,
there's something creepy.
Voice is easy to cop the band gorillas.
I don't know if you know anything about gorillas,
how they tried to rub it out and they're actually been doing this for a while
using holograms in their latest one.
I guess it's just,
I don't know if it's out yet or no,
but they were going to be doing the same kind of technology as this,
but where they go out into the crowd,
like they have like,
like a walkway,
like kind of,
uh,
we're,
you know,
fashion model views or their band members will walk out and in Hall Graham Style
soon you could like do it.
You don't have you record one concert and go home.
[inaudible] he's holograms.
What's the coolest thing about this
exist in that?
That even though the price tag for it,
it was $10 million,
but seeing a movie for your first time back in whenever the 20s or 30s a silent
movie,
it used to be like,
wow,
look at this amazing thing and now you have it on your phone.
So the cool thing about this technology,
it's that,
you know,
it will be coming to us in a cheaper way and form factors somehow.
And we're all going to be star wars in around with our princess layers telling
us the hell.
So what an Eob.
One you'll buy only hope.
Yeah,
yeah,
no shit.
And that was terrible technology.
Princess Leia looked like shit,
that's gonna fucking bring porn back.
Big
ex-girlfriends will very mixed girl Wolf Blitzer
be considered cheating.
No holograms.
You can't fuck a hologram.
So no,
it's not cheating.
But it'd be like,
Oh fuck you.
Fuck a Hologram.
But you use the fleshlight.
But the Hologram was just a video thing.
You're not going to be able to touch it,
but you use it up.
Hold on,
hold on a flash site and you can put the Hologram right on.
You're like,
she's lap dancing and you jack the fleshlight.
You better off just getting real close to it and looking at it and just,
I think it'll work late on the top of the flashlight.
Put her inside a hot hologram and the hologram moves to her.
She's like,
she controls it,
right?
So she has a thin layer of a hologram around that ugly body.
You might be able to Hologram your face.
Oh,
that's a hologram.
That's true.
Good point.
You the grabbing some fucking beautiful person made on your pay.
Makeup's going to be a Hologram
in the future.
Hell yeah,
that'd be cool.
Well yeah,
made you load without a hologram.
Your whole face on.
You could put a different face on magic going out.
Then you talking to a girl and you see like
a lot of times you can go like a hologram.
The only thing is like your Dick,
the the first like half an inch of our lips.
It's like transparent.
Like you could see through it.
What's going on.
This is all here.
It's really good.
I have something to tell you that's my,
but that'd be cool.
Like change clothes,
you know like Ah,
I want a suit.
You know like yeah,
you just walk around naked with a hologram on.
Imagine if,
I mean,
what the fuck man,
there's a lot of places without them might actually be like that might feel
nice.
Big Hologram dicks.
There'll be huge right.
Girls would go to grab it and fall for it.
Don't
grab it.
Yeah,
fall on your face.
That's so fucking interesting idea that we can eventually change the actual
visual visual appearance of things.
You know that we could do it like if you ever seen those walls,
there's like a certain kind of wallpaper and they have that has like lights and
yeah,
like he paper what does it and it changes like what does it,
you turn it on and like what does it,
what does it do exactly what it pretty much,
it's like a photo wall LCD screen where he'll be able to like I that future,
I don't know what that one is but the technology's out where eventually we will
have laws where that would be a screen and you could turn it on I texture or a
color of a wall.
You could turn on the TV on the wall.
You know,
you can make windows where we'll be able to like Skype and one corner on the
other side have just like a fireplace,
minority report type shit.
That's happening man.
That's on the way edge.
Isn't it weird how they,
we've got fat and ugly mastered.
Like you can make someone look fat and ugly but they can't do good looking.
What do you mean fake good looking like,
you know,
like mom big Mama's house.
Oh,
right,
right.
The fat suits.
What a fat became hot.
Like in 20 years.
It probably won't happen.
Dudes are getting fat suits and ship.
It used to be used to be for girls,
used to be a sign of uh,
her being from a wealth cause you can fatten her ass up.
Everybody else was starving to death unless she was warmer
back then.
All you needed was like Turkey and fucking all this food on the table and people
thought you were rich as fuck.
Like,
oh my God,
look at all the food spit just keeps eating.
You just keep eating food.
Like if you're a fat fuck,
that was awesome.
It's like you just can't just sit around and eat.
There was dark times and this species history where people would just scrounging
and scratching and it got to the point where fat,
obese people were sexy because they were desirable.
It's so rare,
so rare.
Someone just can lay around and do nothing and eat.
I can see that coming back for sure.
Sure.
I wonder,
I wonder what time to come.
Right?
Yeah.
I wonder when grabbing chips by the head and dragging him through the fucking
dirt became illegal.
Well,
it might be on the way back.
You look at this Chris Brown thing.
Chris Brown is a huge star beat up.
Rihanna is still a huge star,
bigger star than ever.
And I didn't beat her up again,
but you know what I mean?
Never really.
I mean,
people who didn't really hurt his career.
I mean people talk shit about her,
but it actually probably made a bigger and other friends again,
so it's probably getting more acceptable.
So I like you should it by the way.
There's
some people that accused me of being,
um,
a massage,
earnest Brian Online and I'm so sad.
You've always been.
Every since I was sad.
Do you think for new people that think that it's so sad,
listen,
but if you're a dumb cunt,
yeah,
I'm a massage nest against dump counts only,
but I'm not like against like regular women.
I like Virgo women.
Regular women are some of the nicest people I know.
You know,
they're not burdened by a lot of the testosterone issues that men have.
I don't have any problem with most women,
but dumb dude's,
it's the same if you,
if you don't like dumb dudes and you start shitting on dumb dudes,
nobody ever says you fucking hate dude's exactly hate men.
But if you have any scenario where a chick says something stupid,
even if you generalize and say like,
chick shouldn't be president,
you know,
I don't think men should give birth either.
Don't get me wrong.
I mean,
it's not an even exchange here,
but I certainly am not a massage just by any stretch of the imagination or of
don't filter yourself on,
on sexist.
You know,
when you're [inaudible],
if somebody is being a fucking idiot,
you,
you'll say if the guy or a girl,
and I think that's what it is.
A lot of times I try to be nicest prossible about,
especially now,
you know,
like when you,
especially when you're talking to a chick or a lot of times chicks are a little
bit more sensitive to criticism or the potential possibility that you're a mean
asshole and going to say something mean to her.
I tried to be a lot nicer about it.
Are You going to go pee?
All right.
Good luck with that.
Right now we're just going to talk about me being a massage and a homophobe or
something.
I don't know neither of those things.
I'm not,
I'm no perfect person,
but when I tell you that my real true,
honest feelings and intentions and how I express them on the spot,
not a homophobe at all,
that's silly.
I'm neither that nor am I a sexist person.
I try to be real.
Even with this is a lot of things I don't like.
Don't get me wrong,
I'm not an,
I'm not like a,
a person without adjuncts are a person that doesn't get upset at things and I'm
certainly not enlightened and then shape or form,
but I'm pretty even about what I like and don't like.
If you're nice,
I like you.
I'm,
I'm a fucking easy going guy.
There's a lot of comedians and I don't even,
I can't even watch their act.
They're terrible.
But if they're nice to me,
I'm nice to them.
I'm nice to everybody.
That's nice to me.
That's how I treat the world.
And if you're a woman and you're nice to me,
we're friends,
period.
Since it's that simple.
But for whatever reason,
if he,
was there any ever any conflict of you with a women,
with a women,
with a woman,
with what?
A name,
women folk.
Uh,
if there's any conflict ever and it's documented online,
automatically going to point to that one moment in time and there's a woman
heckler or any of that shit.
The feminist,
the feminist video is a perfect example of me not trying,
trying to not get into a thing with her.
I didn't want to,
I was trying to be nice.
I tried to be nice always until you can't be nice anymore and then you like get
outta here bitch.
You know that's,
it's not my preference.
My preference is certainly it'd be nice.
And you too man.
One of the nicest guys I know.
You know,
one of the cool things about Jujitsu is that the,
the dudes that do it generally speaking,
are so much more relaxed ego wise than your average guy.
And you meet so many nice guys,
like so many people when,
when they have their in check,
when they do Jujitsu and it's fucking hard.
It's not easy to go out there and put your ass on the line and you know,
you work all day and you're tired and then you go to a fucking Jujitsu class,
especially when you're a beginner,
that shit is hard as fuck.
You get your ass kicked.
It's terrible.
But if you can get through that gauntlet,
if you can get through that,
become a Bluebell,
become a purple belt.
There's like certain qualities that those guys have about them.
They're just more relaxed.
Like Mike Maxwell,
the guy who does my poster.
Do you see my poster?
I did for the Chicago show?
No Dude,
this guy is so talented and he just did another one for me for the Atlanta show.
He's got to what his website,
Mike Maxwell,
art.com he's a,
he's a blue belt and he's a,
he's trains with a Nogueira down in San good with graphics graphics.
Great,
brilliant,
brilliant artist.
But he's got,
he's got that same sort of personality about him.
He's a great guy.
He's easy going cause the dude trains,
he trains,
he gets,
he doesn't have any weird insecurity issues like a lot of people have.
You know,
there's a lot of dudes out there I think in it not having a martial art.
And obviously I'm extremely biased when I voiced his opinion and it's not for
everybody.
Like obviously I don't think it's for Brian.
Everybody's personality is different.
Brian has no desire to do any of that stuff.
But for a lot of people they do.
You're in but you're not insecure about like getting into a situation where you
get into fight with guys.
He was just,
you'll just get out of there.
There's a lot of guys who were in their manhood is threatened.
They want to puff up their chests and they can get in trouble and it's a scary
moment for them.
Opposite of that,
you are so I'm,
I don't say it's for everybody.
We all have their own paths in life,
but for a lot of people he can fucking help tremendously.
It's a missing part of our lives.
We are our whole body of this.
The system,
the way the mind operates is all essentially set up for conflict.
We're set up for physical activity,
for conflict.
We're set up for,
for figuring out who's the alpha of the chimpanzee,
the human thing,
whatever the fuck we are.
I mean every,
every animal has,
has alpha.
Every a primate rather has like that Alpha structure and that's what we have to,
we have this constant competition but it doesn't happen and instead it manifests
itself as business,
which is weird and buttoned down with strange clothes and weird rules and no
swears and there's a lot of restrictions.
There's a lot of suppression suppressing the true instincts of the animal,
the human organism and Jujitsu allows you to express the true instincts of the
animal organism in a safe way that actually you benefit from and you develop
character from.
You know,
and there's,
there's,
there's a real benefit to that that obviously you experience obviously I
experienced and you give out when you're teaching Jujitsu,
when you're,
what you're doing with 10 planets,
10th planet,
Jiu Jitsu with a website,
with offering the,
mastering the system so you can watch different techniques and learn from them
online.
We read what you're doing as you're spreading this incredible tool to become a
better human being.
You spreading this incredible tool to,
to help you master your own personal space a little bit better.
Look at that,
Eddie Bravo.
Well thank you very much.
That was bitches.
Thank you.
Thank,
I appreciate that.
Now you say,
you were saying that it's terrible and you get your ads.
It's awful in the beginning.
You don't mean that.
Let me clarify that.
He doesn't mean it's terrible.
Like you have just a terrible time.
He means terrible.
Like if you started playing a new video game for the first time and you're going
to one on one against people,
they would be killing you and it's terrible.
You're losing all the time,
but no one's really getting hurt.
You're not going to get hurt on Jujitsu.
It's not terrible or you're getting hurt.
You might get hurt like at the same rate as you would play in basketball three
times a week going to fuck your shoulder up.
You might fuck your knee up,
twist an ankle.
It's the same thing.
I've been doing Jujitsu 18 years.
I've never needed surgery.
It was pretty amazing.
I know a lot of guys like that.
Eventually you will tweet,
you know you can tweak your knee.
You might tear an ACL,
you might need some surgery,
but it's no,
it's actually super safe and when I say terrible,
what I really mean is like,
you're not going to win.
That's all it is.
It's really fun to learn though and you,
before you even spar,
you're going to go through drills where you're showing the technique and you
execute it on someone who was not resisting.
And by learning it that way you know you do and putting the repetitions you
eventually absolutely can develop those techniques.
The beautiful thing about the techniques that you Jitsu is most of them don't
even require any real unusual physical attributes.
You don't have to be unusually strong.
You just have to have leverage in position and a lot of people could apply.
A lot of people out there don't even work out if you taught them a rear naked
choke and then you let them put it on you,
they could put you to sleep.
People don't even work out,
they don't even train.
The techniques are really that effective,
you know,
so you'll get better.
It's 100% you'll get better.
You just have to put in the numbers.
And that's one of the things that are really always appreciated about the way
you talk about Jujitsu is a,
you are always really humble in that,
that regard.
And you're always make sure that you let people know that there's nothing
unusual but you,
you're not a great athlete.
This is not,
this is all just thinking and putting in the numbers and doing the proper
technique and anyone can do it and you,
oh yeah,
children do it,
old ladies do it.
It's never too late to do it.
You can,
it doesn't matter if you're 50 or 60 42 if you want to learn how to subdue
someone and put them to sleep scientifically in a very nonviolent way,
you're doing it with a bunch of nerds.
It's Jujitsu itself has a Douche bag filter.
We've talked about that before.
Douchebags can handle getting tap can handle losing a game of death.
Even though no one gets hurt,
their ego gets hurt.
So it automatically keeps Douche bags out.
So that's a few sneak in every now and then they do.
But you know,
every time I'm on the podcast,
we talk about this,
you know,
I know beaten,
you know I'm beating everyone over the head with this,
but there's Jujitsu everywhere.
There's every practically every city has a Jujitsu school.
Find a Jujitsu school,
whether it's no gay are gay,
get into it because within a year and time flies within a year,
sometimes even six months depending on how fast you pick it up.
But at the most a year you will be able to take an untrained man and a dude who
doesn't do Jujitsu obviously.
And most people don't.
If anything goes wrong,
you know,
at the movie theater with your family,
with your kids,
with your girlfriend,
someone steps up,
you will have the confidence to put that guy to sleep and just extinguish the
problem.
And it gives you so much confidence and not just those type situations but an
everyday situations in business and meetings you just said cause you so much
confidence knowing if anything goes down,
you're safe to,
I wonder if they're ever going to be able to come out with a Jujitsu dummy that
is a robot that works on a computer and knows how to execute moves.
Yes,
I'll give you.
Yeah because if you see like these,
I don't know if you'd want to roll with it cause when my fucking kill you
because maybe if we get,
if they could get it to be like super sensitive,
you know,
maybe,
I don't know man.
The way they're doing it now,
the robots they have now,
they can push them while they're running and they like lean over and then
rebalance themselves and come back up or they're getting super,
super advanced and I think it's the,
the human body,
like the anatomy,
they already understand it completely.
They know exactly where the bones go.
They know if they created some sort of an artificial structure that mimic bone
mass and they'd figured out a way to power it and move it around and then
figured out a way to make it like ultra sensitive to compression and how much it
squeezing and how,
what,
what position it's in,
and then make it work like a Jujitsu fucking fire
finish your garage.
Really good defense.
So you worked on your offense,
like he's constantly escaping your shit.
Do you want them to attack a little bit scared that yeah.
Maybe you have to calibrate your netting fence.
You know what I mean?
You have to calibrate your neck and make sure it doesn't squeeze.
Be Honest.
That's scary to people.
You're going to die.
You know?
We know that to a year at least,
the tapping malfunction,
you cigarettes kill a lot of people and they're still smoking cigarettes.
Be People fight man.
Yeah.
If they're responsible guys,
they weren't trained.
That would be the,
yeah,
that would be the argument.
We would say,
listen man,
cigarettes kill 400,000 people every year.
A few dudes got jacked by the Jujitsu dummy.
All right.
I'm not getting jacked my mind.
And you could buy one if you are really a low star,
you could buy a black belt one and it's talking shit as you take it out of the
box.
I really bitch.
You think you ready for this really big?
You can imagine we can get a white belt one and just fucking strangle it.
Or you can get like different kinds of athletes,
like 190 pound football player,
like one of those ridiculously powerful and explosive defensive end dudes.
How big would a defensive end?
B,
285 pounds.
How about that?
How about a 285 pound one and you only,
you only attack it.
It only does defense.
You just gotta it's constantly trying to peel you off of it,
but it gets tired like a 280 pound man too.
Maybe it only has like a certain day calculate.
It's anaerobic capacity.
Like if it's muscles are like Bob Sapp style big,
you just got to figure out how to ride it,
but it won't ever spike you on your head like Bob Sapwood.
Nice.
It's possible.
Right.
I think maybe by 2023
I wonder if anybody ever bought a gay real doll to use it as a Jujitsu dummy and
be like,
yeah,
just choking and it's very realistic,
you know,
I don't like,
I,
I mean when I do choke and I fuck it,
but that's,
listen,
this is the survival of the fittest.
Have they made entire thing down?
It's like an unsaid advancements with a real dog.
Cause how we're starting here,
we used to push that 20 years ago.
The real dom must be amazing.
Or did they,
did they plateau?
Hmm.
That's a good question.
Let's go to the prom now.
The biggest problem is,
is that even now,
they are definitely better now and there's actually companies that that make
real doll knock off or the same technology is real doll,
but they do better every year.
Do they keep getting better?
All conventions.
We had a guy on one of our shows a night.
He showed the Christmas roast video and they had a couple of real dollars there
and they were awesome looking.
But then the vagina,
which felt like a fleshlight rip off,
like it wasn't as good for,
you're viewing an iPhone right now.
Like the latest iPhone stuff.
We're fucking,
I don't think it's there like I,
I really do think like the flashlights,
one of the best feeling because they patent it.
Put a fucking flashlight.
You put a flashlight inside one.
Like there's like,
yeah,
you got a Pepsi.
Yeah,
absolutely.
If you don't know the whole deck.
No,
they have tranny ones.
Oh look at this training.
What they have training foot.
Um,
real dolls.
They have a real dog.
That's a girl with a Dick.
Yeah.
It looks like her Bush is shaped in the tap out logo.
Oh,
hilarious.
No,
they can't see it real.
That's not fake.
No.
Go to real doll.com and look at shemale double double one.
Throw that up on the,
Oh,
we can't put it on Ustream.
Jesus Christ.
What am I talking about it?
Listen,
don't listen to me.
This is completely illegal.
Did you get shutdown?
Ustream shut you down.
Yeah.
Well,
here's the thing,
I that's cool that you talked about this,
that you stream is a,
uh,
business,
you know,
like they have advertisers and while they've been nice enough to take the
advertising off our shows and stuff like that,
they do have to kind of have this kind of policy,
you know,
and one of the content,
yeah,
one of the policies is believe it or not,
marijuana use any kind of drug use while it might be legal in California showing
us take bongs and stuff like that.
So it was it from the icehouse chronicles.
It's from a couple of things.
Uh,
ice house chronicles,
there was a naughty showed that I had just put up,
uh,
today where there's,
there was a quick nudity where the girl like took off her clothes and I grabbed
the camera at the last second and I think there was a little bit of new dude
that Shit.
But still I pulled the video immediately when that happened,
you know,
so no one could else could see it.
But I still think there's a lot of people that watch this,
that you know,
that marijuana would bug Kodak or you know,
Ford Motor unit.
If they were a sponsor,
they're not going to be like,
why,
why are we sponsoring bong hits?
And Rob was just to the government plan nine 11 who would be fishing.
Especially she,
yeah.
So I mean it's totally understandable.
So I just got to remember to remember that for future use.
But luckily,
you
know,
Brad is a good buddy ourselves.
So he hooked it back up and tell you to delete those or anything?
Uh,
no,
I just pulled him.
I already had him poured.
I think it was just,
it was automatic wash them.
Those on Vimeo,
Vimeo,
just going to death squad.
Dot.
TV.
[inaudible] DOT TV on Vimeo.
Yeah.
That's um,
that's a tricky situation.
Yeah.
I could see that.
There's a lot of parts of this country where they have archaic marijuana laws.
Like we need sit there and do shots on camera and it's no problem at all.
Right.
We might have to limit it to the drinking room.
Smaller outside has no rules.
Do you could put any music?
No,
know they have rules.
It's just a little bit more lenient because you're paying for it and there's no
advertising involved.
This is more of a pay.
Vimeo is more of a paid service where like you can have a director and he'd got
a short movie that has new DNA,
then you most likely are going to be fine because it's kind of art.
You could use anybody's,
no,
I wouldn't say you could use anyone to music,
but there's also the,
the laws on music's really fucking weird anyways.
They tell you do not use any music,
but if you're talking over music and incentive background and you know,
does that count or who knows a lot of gray areas for that.
Okay.
I'm going to Giorgio sucralose this site to look at his new clothes.
Oh Dude.
He's got the greatest shirt ever.
Whereas he's got a purple shirt that has a face and white really big with his
hair.
You know,
hair is bigger than ever and it says super delicious.
Oh my goodness.
No,
he doesn't giant.
Oh my gosh.
You're looking at it.
It's the greatest shit ever.
I would wear that on the podcast.
Georgia.
You've got to get me one of these silly bitch.
Look at us.
Oh,
so delicious.
Hey,
he's running with it,
man.
He's running with that whole UFO thing.
Dude.
He's really funny.
On four Chan.
You ever seen him?
He goes on four Chan.
The Photoshop seems other mediums did four Chan get someone killed probably.
Is that true?
I guess you didn't hear that.
No,
I didn't know some of that.
Some fire related thing.
Someone that desert,
someone said that it was on but it could be totally a troll probably.
Who knows,
but I wouldn't,
I could believe that.
I mean 14 is just a collection of people is a question that did fortune get
someone killed as the question I left working for channel and anonymous.
Yeah,
I do too.
I don't know this.
I'm reading this off some fucking wanky website.
It could be totally horse shit.
Okay.
They,
they keep busting those dudes though.
It's just set.
Another four Chan user gets busted by the FBI.
All that was already there was a while ago actually.
What are those guys do exactly.
All right.
Four hanging.
Yeah.
Everyone's terrified.
If anyone like that anonymous four Chan,
anybody's on the Internet.
I'm just fucked your shit up kid.
Well,
I don't know what the four Chan guys,
if 14 is a little different,
that's just a message.
It's crazy for him,
right?
It's like the most brutal forum on the whole Internet is just take a photo
board.
Like I was just fun photos and a lot of creepy sex shit.
But like a lot of the like Internet memes originate there,
right?
The law cats didn't they originate there?
I'm not 100% sure,
but yeah,
that's the theory.
Right?
So or the pictures with the tech side,
there's one on my message board,
there's a picture of the dude all fucked up and he's all bleeding and I'll top
it says at first I thought it was a great idea to throw trash into the dolphin
pool,
but I didn't know Matt Horwitz was standing right behind me.
That's funny.
That's Laird's.
There's those are great man.
The Internet,
like random Internet comedy that comes out of some of those things.
Some are so fun,
man.
It was so fun.
Some really hilarious things have been created on the sucralose ones.
I'm not saying it's aliens,
but it was aliens.
It's like so many of them here with his fucking hair.
All crazy in the meme as an alien mean.
Some of those are so funny,
dude.
There's something funny fucking people out there that are trapped in regular
jobs,
you know?
I'm hoping that's what America,
well that's what I was going to be our next industry.
Funny Shit we produce on the Internet where they eventually people figured out
how to make a living just completely straight from the Internet creating either
podcasts or web series or different things they do.
It's like this is a lot of funny fucking dudes out there.
Definitely for entertainment.
This is the best time in the whole entire room.
Like if you're giving me these use musician,
by the way.
Hi honey.
Honey honeys new video that we are in.
It comes out Thursday and I think it's going to be on IFC dot [inaudible] dot
com we're in a music video,
bro.
Yeah,
it was air guitar and playing with my butt and I was playing with his,
but
we were just standing around looking like retards,
really acting.
We were hanging out at park.
We were at date at a party.
We were at a date.
I think we look at girls mandates.
We were on a mandate.
Scott reaffirmed the haters.
The director.
You're like,
hey,
is it okay if we were just like slow dancing or or something like that.
They kind of talked to us out of it.
That would have been cool.
I know.
I thought it would be cool.
Yeah.
I think they were like,
oh,
well that would have been rude though.
We're sending a weird message in the middle of their video.
That's not our business to do that.
Turn your video.
No.
Gay Porn again.
Love of fun.
Yeah.
They were at Coachella.
I listened to in my hotel room.
I was in Fort Lauderdale and in the hotel room.
I was watching the live Coachella feed on Ustream or youtube rather.
It's pretty bad ass.
It's great.
You go full screen with it.
It's totally HD.
It looked amazing.
It was really fun.
Really A,
it was fun to watch their,
uh,
their fucking killing it out there,
man.
They're going to be back next week.
Are they?
What are they doing this weekend?
Coachella again.
Oh really?
Yeah,
she was on stage and talking about how Suzanne was that she,
the last time she was there,
she was selling barbecue at one of the stands.
So she was like,
just to let you know,
barbecue is the route to the stage here.
Coachella.
She's hot.
She's ridiculously talented,
too.
Ridiculously.
That,
that chick's voice is amazing.
There's,
so I got into a thing online with some fucking dude on the board.
Just cut.
So Conti about some,
there's this chick named Nicky Balaam,
I think her name is,
and she does that.
A rendition of Linda Ronstadt's.
You're no good while inside
of a,
um,
inside of van.
Have you heard it?
You haven't just seen it,
dude.
You gotta you gotta hear this.
It just put it on for a couple minutes because it's,
it's them singing this song in a van and this,
this chick has fucking incredible voice.
Just Nikki B,
l u h m or something like that.
You're no good while you apostrophe.
What did someone say or armor?
He said some dude was,
oh,
some dude was shitting on it like,
you know I,
I was saying,
you know,
how how much talent is chick has.
And some dude was like,
you know,
no,
that soaks it.
Shit.
This is better.
And I,
I fucking get crazy when people tell me that what you like sucks.
Like why,
why it does you don't like it.
We can't say it sucks.
It just,
it's that chicken fucking sing.
It might not be your style in music.
It might not be something that you would get into my mom.
You,
it might not be in the right frequency to de de de de tune into it.
You might not enjoy that kind of music,
but so many people enjoy it.
It's the one,
the upper left.
Oh,
the,
yeah,
the one.
Yeah.
Right.
Nope.
Above it.
Okay.
Are you allowed to play it on your podcast?
Yeah.
You could play this for a couple seconds.
Check it out.
Why?
Just driving.
I heard this
chick's voice,
man crying.
Can you move your arm for second
through?
Yeah,
I see how you
damn that bitch can say,
hey
baby,
I love that voice,
man.
This
is awesome.
That's like soulful,
you know that's a smoky,
oh dude,
it's a,
it's a hot video man.
It's,
it's,
it's really,
it's inspirational too.
I liked it.
They're on their way to a Gig and they're just playing in a van,
you know?
And she's just sitting there with an iPhone and recording it and it's beautiful,
man.
There's not,
there's no special effects.
There's no nothing.
And it's one of my favorite videos,
man.
I'm,
that's a,
I don't know what it is,
man,
but at chick with a bad ass voice,
it like makes my body feel better.
I like it.
It's Susan,
me,
it puts me into a frame of mind that is almost unavailable to me without like
being in love with female voices.
I love the female.
It's incredible.
Rama Glock on,
that's one of my favorite.
Oh Dude.
I was in a pool hall in fucking White Plains,
New York.
And that first Sarah Pailin video or set pair,
Sarah Pailin,
split of the flux at Sarah McLaughlin.
Sarah McLaughlin video came up this sin
possession.
Yeah.
You know that song.
And I remember looking up and just go,
God damn.
And the dude was like,
Hey,
come on man,
it's your shot.
I was like,
I don't even want to play anymore.
I wanted to watch that video.
I was like,
I was hypnotized.
It's like Holy Shit.
If she kills it every time I've heard time,
I went,
dude,
I went to last minute.
Sarah McLaughlin was playing Hollywood bowl about a year ago,
and I was like,
I told my girlfriend she's playing tonight.
I didn't even know you want to go.
It's not sold out.
My Buddy Tom,
he goes,
dude,
it's not sold out.
He reminded me,
you should go.
So we went to,
showed up,
did we just show we're just going to buy any tickets?
And some guy comes up and goes,
you,
you know anybody who needs to do you need two tickets.
You know they were from work that he got right through like probably
maybe 20 yards from her right in front of her amazing seats.
We totally lucked out right there in the front.
And she destroyed the Hollywood bowl.
She went out there barefoot and she killed it.
She has this background center cause you know obviously on record she does a lot
of layers.
It's like 10 Sarah's sometimes three,
sometimes four.
It's a choir of her,
but she has his backup singer that sounds just like her.
She's been with her for years.
Amazing.
She's like a star too.
She's the chick who makes Sarah sound good cause she's backing her up.
You know the both amazing man.
It's crazy.
She's probably like one of the most famous background singers,
you know.
Shit.
And Sarah Maclaughlin still touring.
She's too,
yeah.
Does she tore a lot?
Fuck.
She just got divorced.
New Life.
Maybe like a year ago,
wife was a mom.
I was fumbling,
fumbling towards ecstasy that I'm fumbling towards ecstasy.
One of the greatest albums ever.
Man.
That's well possessions on this track.
One.
That whole album is amazing.
Fumbling towards ecstasy.
Incredible.
Sane voice.
I really hate that stupid pet commercial though.
Her Song using
the song you don't like.
Yeah,
I don't like that song.
It's where there's a lot of songs on that holy that into,
I mean some albums she only has one good song,
the whole album,
you know.
Uh,
but um,
I still love her cause overall she's got like 15 amazing songs,
like even surfacing had four or five great songs.
Are you trying to find out what it looks like?
Brian?
Sarah,
she's still hot.
She gets extra talent points.
Uh,
yeah.
He used to be so honored to be in her presence,
presence of her vagina.
If she let you into the fold.
I saw her,
I Valentine's Day.
Can you imagine you're hanging out and she's like serenading and shit.
It'd be like a little bitch.
Yeah.
I bought tickets for my girlfriend to see her on Valentine's Day and like 1998
and it was like the hottest thing ever.
My girlfriend wasn't really even into Sarah McLaughlin at all until that show.
She got blown away.
It was at and shit.
She kills everything.
Her voice is never off.
She's amazing,
effortless,
just you know,
angelic voice.
Just like some song.
I mean I love the black keys.
I mean it doesn't have to be a girl singing to get me,
but does a certain thing that a girl sing and does.
It's a different thing.
It's a different,
like girls can do different things,
you know,
they could do their,
you,
they have a more octaves they could sing and yeah,
it's just the way it reacts or the Way Your Body rather reacts to the,
the beautiful harmonic sound of a beautiful female voice.
It's like,
wow,
you know,
your whole body just goes,
wow.
It's amazing thing.
What sound can do,
dude,
when we think about the information that's being transferred between people,
you know,
the,
the lyrics and the notes and all of it together and the impact that it has on
your,
your whole body and you're feeling though.
I mean there's songs that give you goosebumps or songs make you want to run up
hills.
There's songs that I used to listen to offspring when I uh,
when I would hit the bag because Austin is like,
everything is like fucking go,
go.
It's all just inquiry.
It makes you work out harder.
Like you listen to a fucking old offspring album.
That shit will make you work out hard.
The pace is so frenetic and makes you just to fucking attack,
attack,
attack.
There's nothing else that can do that.
No.
A guy standing next to you is,
I'm going to do that.
Like there's something about music that just like fucking,
we used the band I was in back when I was 18 resistance where speed metal band.
We used to share rehearsal rooms with offspring.
Whoa.
Yeah.
That was just the leave the room smelling like petroleum oil.
I couldn't believe they got so huge like holy shit.
We used to practice with these guys.
Wow.
It's amazing.
Back a DC sparks and off a and Anaheim,
they have some of my favorite workout music over.
She's just fucking for going crazy berserker style like for hidden things so
fast.
We just want,
if you are going to do rounds on a bag or something and listen to some
offspring,
it's amazing that that like really good music can make cardio actually like go
buy.
Like if you put on like a fucking Badass.
Um,
specially if you smoke a little weed and a lot of people think that that's
counterproductive to cardio work.
But I say,
how dare you look at Nick ideas.
Yeah.
Look at Nick Diaz.
You is still alive and kicking Nick Diaz Braulio Schema.
Holy Shit.
Oh,
that's going to be May 12th,
right?
May 13th May 12th May 12th May 12th where's that,
that fight?
It's uh,
there's no,
there's a world Jujitsu expo happening in Los Angeles.
I'm not,
I think in Long Beach or something.
I'm not sure either la convention or at Long Beach May 12th World Jujitsu Expo
and there's going to be a few super fights.
A lot of top Jiu Jitsu guys are doing seminars like Robert Drysdale,
I think Andrea vows doing a drug,
all the big dudes and broadly steamer who is arguably the best pound for pound
Jujitsu guy on the planet.
Him and Marcello right up there.
Um,
he's going against Nick Diaz match.
Do you know Bruce met a couple times?
He's been totally go on.
A fucking great guy hears.
Did you even know with him in England?
Yeah.
Oh Shit.
[inaudible] he was recently some translating over there a couple of times we
hung out with him.
He's a great guy.
He's a great good.
So down to earth.
Such a really nice guy.
Like if you were,
we were hanging around talking behind a backstage,
like at the lands and one of the shows.
If you didn't know him,
man,
you would,
you would never assume that this guy is one of the baddest motherfuckers on
earth when it comes Jujitsu.
He just seems so friendly and easy going and so on.
Assuming he's going to do it for that as well.
Wow.
Dude.
He's gonna fuck some people up,
man.
That Jujitsu is nasty.
He's so technical.
So,
so what do you think Nec Braulio who knows?
It's going to be awesome.
I would never say,
even if I thought,
listen,
tell you something,
man.
Nick Diaz is the opening to my podcast,
so I'll never say anything bad about nick tells probably us to meet steam as a
motherfucker,
but shows you how ballsy he has is.
He's not just taking a super fight against anybody taking a super fight against
the best.
I mean,
he's just jumping in and doing,
having an opportunity where he could get submitted,
you know,
easily.
He might shock the world.
Can you never know,
could you imagine that they'd like Triangle Braulio?
Can you imagine?
Imagine that would be,
especially if it was high as Jesus on a space shuttle,
that would definitely make ESPN.
Definitely.
That's going to get so much coverage.
Nick Diaz is a fucking UFC rockstar.
Yeah,
he's going to do a super fight.
No one.
They never any man,
you know he liked locked Makoko.
He finished Makoko.
You know Nick Diaz can finish anyway,
if anybody sleeps on Nick Diaz,
he can do the biggest Jujitsu match of all time.
I think.
So.
This is the biggest Jujitsu.
You have a salt.
Yeah.
Because a lot of people and thought that Nick Diaz should've got the nod in that
fight against Carlos condit.
So that would make him,
in their opinion.
And that's not just a few,
you know,
I don't,
I,
I've said I thought he could have won,
but I could see the,
I could see how you could scored for Carlos to,
I will if I would have leaned towards nick.
But it was a very fucking close fight.
Just say it was a draw.
Let's pretend it was a draw or even just a close loss.
You're talking about one of the very best guys in MMA going up against the very
best car,
one of the very best guys in Jujitsu.
That never happens.
Never.
This is the biggest Jujitsu Strikeforce champion.
I mean,
when was the last time,
George Saint Pierre jumped in and fought novel dobby and what was it,
2003 five five 2005 yeah.
Right.
It was La,
right?
Yeah.
And,
and he jumped in there too.
He wasn't as famous.
It wasn't as famous,
not as Nick Diaz is right now.
MMA wasn't as big.
This was all pre a ultimate.
No,
it wasn't was it?
That's what a lot of balls and from GSP,
he said,
fuck it.
I'm doing Abu Dhabi GSPS.
He's another guy.
Look at it.
Look how fucking Nice that guy.
He goes,
yeah,
I remember hanging out with him.
He's the nicest guy ever.
Just such a sweetheart and so unassuming.
Again,
same thing,
so completely unassuming.
The fact that he would even allow me to teach him a kick,
that he would waste his time to come down to the gym to work out with me.
You know,
there's just a that he would even try that you know?
It just shows you what a nice guy.
You know how crazy that video is?
No crazy.
Here.
Here we got George Saint Pierre,
the Michael Jordan of MMA.
MMA is the hottest sport on the planet.
UFC is the biggest sport on the planet,
or hottest rising.
Here's George Saint Pierre taking,
spinning back kick lessons from you on video.
Even Bruce lead that can't,
doesn't have like that.
There's no Bruce leave video footage of Bruce showing the baddest fighter on the
planet how to kick.
Well,
this is what I'm saying.
You know,
look,
I'm not,
there's a lot of things that I'm not that good.
I'm just saying that video is fucking historic.
Oh yeah.
What I'm saying is there's not a lot of things that I'm,
I'm,
I'm not good at a lot of things,
but there's a few things I'm really good at and I'm really good at kicking shit.
I can kick shit hard and that's something I've done since I was a little kid.
I've been throwing taekwondo kicks in,
so it's growing.
This is,
my body was growing and before youtube,
before the,
you know,
the Internet where it is today,
I knew how hard you kicked man.
I was trying to tell people no one would believe me.
I would say do Joe Rogan kicks harder than anybody I've ever seen.
And they're like,
whatever,
whatever.
Nobody believed that.
God dammit.
It's one of those things.
Anybody that just develops,
if you like,
spend 10 years working on one specific thing,
like,
look how good Marcello Garcia has.
We're naked.
Choke is,
you know why?
Cause he just hit that over and over and over again to put those numbers.
If you look at the way Jimmy Hendrix used to play guitar,
why could he play guitar so good?
Because he just hit those numbers over and over and over and over and it became
a part of his body.
The thing you can learn about someone throwing a crazy spinning back kick is
what's possible when someone just dedicates insane hours to one technique over
and over and over again.
So my hands were fucking terrible dude until I was like 20 years old.
I had no boxing technique at all.
I didn't develop my hands.
I learned how to throw straight punches and I learned how to throw hooks.
But when I would box with people,
I would get killed my fucking up.
My hands are always down low.
My Chin was up too high and get punched in the face.
I still a box and my friend Mike Blight,
he was a,
a former professional boxer and he used to beat me up.
He was fucking make me not be able to kick them.
And just put the gloves on me just kicked my ass.
I didn't really know how to use my hands cause all that time was just spent
developing kicks,
but when you're trying to be like a martial arts superstar like George Saint
Pierre of mixed martial arts guy,
mixed martial arts and choir,
so many different skills.
You've got to work on your wrestling,
you're going to work on this,
you've got to work on that to develop one technique that takes an incredible
amount of time to get really proficient at like it was spinning crazy kicks.
Those take a long time before you really develop that full body coordination
like that.
The moves in the 360 degree roundhouse kick when you step and run at somebody,
those are just like tying a shoe lace.
It just,
it sinks into place where it just becomes a part of your life.
I don't think,
okay,
now I'm going to step with the left and then I'm going to pivot on the ball of
my foot and then put the heel down and then lift the knee up and then kick.
I don't even think that.
I just don't just don't do it like you do.
When you,
when you hit that twist or role,
how many times you hit that twist her role.
When you're inside control and you hooked that left foot under your knee,
just just go for a ride.
It's just a part of your body.
It's a part of the way you know your,
your,
your body interacts with this universe,
you,
it,
it's ingrained in you.
It's a path that's grooved in Warren.
So smooth.
It just automatically goes,
you're executive producing and you're not making the commands no more.
You're just overseeing shit.
Yeah.
It was not a weird feeling,
man.
When you just,
especially what you did to what's happening too quick for you to even think,
but all of a sudden you,
you got someone's back.
You know,
there's just been this mad scramble of adjusting positions in everything you've
done.
It's been completely on training and everything he'd done has been on repetition
and drilling and,
and just putting in the numbers.
And so then while you're alive,
while you're actually rolling to mad scramble habits and your hooks go in and,
and you got a person's back,
you don't even know what you did.
You don't even know what you did.
You barely know what you did.
You just sort of did it.
Yup.
It's crazy.
Same thing with playing guitar or piano,
any shredding on piano.
They're not making any commands.
They're just kind of executive producing the project.
They're like,
let's play that thing.
It's a producer's takeover.
That inside unknown producer.
Yeah.
Creativity is such a fucking amazing thing,
man.
The ability to come up with something that wasn't there.
That's what a weird thing that is that so satisfying.
You know,
and I know you feel it,
Brian.
I mean,
that's how Brian and I met because Brian would just make everybody laugh.
These silly fucking videos he would put online,
you know?
But you know that when you're putting something like that out there and then
somebody reacts to it and somebody likes it and boom,
it's just like to up,
you know,
getting good at something,
creating something good that gets recognized as something good and creating
something good where it,
while you're doing it,
it's sort of just playing out and then,
oh,
there it is.
Now it's done.
I guess everybody's ran out of gas and to this God damn pocket.
So we learned a lot today,
ladies and gentlemen.
We learned about positivity,
positive experiences.
What I love,
what I want to say is after that world Jujitsu Expo,
yes,
that night and Hollywood,
I'm having my birthday party at Bardot and Hollywood.
It's on vine,
like a block north of Hollywood boulevard,
Bardo.
My band smoked,
smoked serpents plan.
No cover.
Just say you're no cover.
That's crazy.
You just saw that on the Joe Rogan experience podcast.
You're going to have what they call packets.
Do you know what a packet is?
What does that,
that's what the people in my message board called Po.
It's a mixture of podcast and faggot and so they call them packets.
Well,
it's real snow cover.
If you said he was there for my birthday party,
well that's ridiculous,
dude.
You're going to get a,
it's going to be overwhelmed.
I'm not even remember to come.
I'm not gonna be able to fit in there.
It's going to be stuffed by the time we get there.
I doubt it.
There'll be like 12 people there just fucked up,
son.
You just fucked up.
So I put a high ticket every once.
A weird dudes with weird colds are going to want to shake your hand.
No Shit,
no shot.
It'd be cool after that World Expo out,
you go watch Nick Diaz and Brawley esteem.
I'll go home,
take a shower,
go get something to eat,
then meet me for my birthday bash at Bardot.
Smoked Serpent's going to rock goddamn house.
10th Planet J j.com.
All my Jujitsu is there.
Click.
I'm thinking about being a backup dancer for this event.
I'm thinking about going and dragging in a bag of them down.
So it'd be like a body builder.
We need bodybuilders instead of blonde wig instead of strippers just oil.
This oil,
I'm going to shave everything.
I'm just going to shave my legs for the first time ever.
Shave everything.
Just go up there.
All oil up.
Where's my manic and close some of your mannequin clothes I've been buying.
Yeah.
You got a lot of glare,
dude.
That fucking Linda Blair you sent me that thing looks dope.
Extra Sister Linda Blair mechanical extra system.
It got shipped out yesterday or today or something like that.
Oh,
I'm so jealous.
I have to get an American Werewolf in London one.
I got a Predator one from that dude who you know who came to the UFC.
You've got to
no,
no.
That's,
that's ridiculous.
Expensive,
but they do recreation's the American Werewolf in London.
They do a recreation of it.
It's just big fucking on all fours.
Eddie Bauer.
Don't give a shit about that stuff,
Huh?
It's all good.
We were surprised.
We all have different tastes and if anybody wants to learn some Jujitsu,
you went to come to Hollywood.
My friend and Linda don't put the choke in.
You'll come to legends,
legends in Hollywood.
I'm,
I'm back.
My numbness has completely gone.
I've been a wreck for months,
man.
I fucked up and pulled a muscle in my back.
And you know,
I,
the,
one of the things that happens in Jujitsu,
Jujitsu is so fun.
Then when you get injured,
you don't think,
man,
I've got to stop doing it.
You did.
So you just think,
wow,
how long ago have to wait before I can do Jujitsu again.
He'll my shit back up.
So I'll be there soon.
And that's a legends in Hollywood is on Santa Monica Boulevard and it's east of
the one on one.
The address is 51 76 Santa Monica Boulevard.
Enter on Kingsley.
It's called legends MMA.
That's what 10th planet headquarters is located.
Also,
I got 30 locations worldwide,
got a 10th planet j J.
Dot.
Com.
Um,
also I got some seminars coming up.
PHOENIX,
April 28th,
Spokane and May,
uh,
Chicago January or June 9th,
Stockholm two day workshop in Stockholm,
June 16th,
something like that.
I got El Paso coming up.
Just go to the Nibiru forum at 10th Planet J J.
Dot Com.
That's where all the seminar info is.
Phoenix's first though,
two weeks when you have something,
we'll serve a snake.
Smoked serpent rather have something that people can buy.
Oh,
you can go on iTunes.
You buy right now.
Yeah,
you can go on iTunes and um,
the Song Jujitsu,
which you could also,
there's a video for if you go to youtube,
search to Jujitsu,
smoke serpent.
We've got it.
We've got a video up.
Uh,
dropped and Jujitsu are both available on iTunes.
Now.
You eventually going to put like a full CD out?
Yes,
yes.
Track at a time as we finish him,
you know,
so all right.
My brother,
as always,
big time phone.
We didn't even get a chance to talk about Jon Jones and Rashad Evans.
Fuck,
I'm going to have to go with John Jones.
Man.
I think he's just too much.
He could get caught.
Rashad does have power.
He does have a speed.
He does have explosiveness.
He,
I,
you know,
we might say John John's just collapse and drop.
I want big bomb,
but my money's on John Jones.
I think he's going to be cautious.
I think,
uh,
I think he's gonna out Wrestle Rashad and really beat him up on the ground.
Wow.
That'd
be amazing to see because Michelle looked amazing against Phil Davis,
especially in the scrambles wound up on top of virtually every time,
you know,
and his standup was just Phil Davis couldn't handle the stand up.
He was,
Rashad was good.
It was,
he looked really solid.
And before that finished off Tito.
And I don't think we shots pretty underrated.
And I think one of the things that you got to think,
you've got to take into consideration as a fact,
they trained a lot together so they both get to know each of these little
idiosyncrasies and I'm sure each of them have,
uh,
taken into consideration and adjusted,
but it's going to be fascinating to see what each one knows about each one.
You know,
I know there was,
uh,
some moments that,
they had talked about where were shot and had success in training,
you know,
with John was tired and he was holding them down like they made reference to
this many times.
So it's gonna be interesting to see how much John has progressed since then
because if you look at the way he fights fucking guys like every time you see
him he's like this newer,
better version,
more confident,
more and more relaxed.
Total destruction,
destruction.
I mean the way he strangled with Leo Machida and then just dropped him down
there.
I mean that's their common opponent.
Right.
And you know,
Machida of course was the first guy to,
not the only condominium owner.
They felt rampage as well.
But Machida was the first guy and the only guy in the UFC to beat Rashad.
Rashad won the ultimate fighter is a fucking heavyweight and then dropped down
to light heavyweight and he's still one of the smaller light heavyweights,
you know,
I think,
uh,
he's a dangerous guy for anybody at two oh five.
And I think knowing as much as he knows about Jon Jones is going to be really
fascinating.
Really interesting to see because John is so,
he's,
he looks like a Muhammad Ali right now.
You know what I mean?
He looks like a Mike Tyson.
He looks like a sugar ray Leonard.
When he was in his prime,
he looks like one of these dudes is like,
man,
this dude is just going to start dominating the world.
You know,
he's already dominating the world.
He's already destroying shogun and willing to title and,
and,
and taking out rampage and taking out Machida and putting them to sleep.
I mean,
he's just on another level,
man.
He's on another level and it looks like he's,
what is he 24 or something like that?
How old is he?
He's the youngest guy to ever win the UFC title.
I mean,
I,
I don't think he's even 24 maybe is what if you are in a coma the last fucking
five years and you woke up and people were trying to fill you in on this John
Jones guy and they were just telling you exactly what you just said.
All the guys that he totally went right through and destroy credible,
he would be blown away.
Yeah,
I'd be completely,
he's 24 yeah,
he's 24 24 years old and just every time you see him you're seeing it just a
giant leap.
And it's progress that age when you're really young like that caught Dami can
learn quick.
God Damn.
When you're fully dedicated and as intelligent as he is,
it's going to be interesting to see how good he gets.
It tends to cause most,
most MMA fighters,
they get to a point and once they become famous there they're Jujitsu kind of
plateaus.
You don't see,
you don't see guys famous guys in the UFC all of a sudden get amazing with their
Jujitsu.
They kind of plateau,
wants to become famous,
but John Jones,
he hasn't plateaued yet.
It's just,
it looks better and better.
And when he gets really good,
like Marcello good and he can,
he's,
he's a bad motherfucker.
He can.
But you know what?
I'm really curious to see how they match up.
Really curious to see what happens.
I think this is going to be so fascinating because obviously Rashad acted as
some sort of a mentor to John in the beginning.
It's very obvious,
you know,
and there's,
there's,
it's,
there's so much history.
It's,
and they're so good.
I think like stylistically Rashad's the most dangerous guy for,
for Jon Jones right now.
And if he gets through Joe,
if he gets through Rashad,
then the big question becomes what does he do now?
Does he go to,
I mean,
who does he going to fight it to?
A five now maybe Gustafson cause dust,
customs and just look really good with Thiago Silva.
You know,
he could fight some guys,
but there's no like one standout guy.
Maybe Dan Henderson.
Dan Henderson stands out.
That's a,
Dan Henderson said he wants a title shot.
He'll fight like Anderson at 85 or he'll fight Jon Jones two oh five I think he
prefers to fight at two oh five that could be interesting.
Henderson's a fucking beast,
man.
You can't count him out with anybody.
Yeah.
Henderson's scary dude.
And you know what,
who knows maybe fade or it goes to two oh five maybe he came back to him cut up
at two oh five I would,
yeah.
What you guys are just too big from like big foot was just too big for him.
He just couldn't handle it.
And you know,
the Dan Henderson fight shit,
most people lose the Dan Henderson and he was in it,
you know?
And it wasn't I think fade or still in the mix,
man.
I,
but I think he really needs to start training and eating right and get down at
two oh five and dominate there.
Yeah.
Well he's,
he's certainly got still nasty skills on his feet.
His submissions have always been great.
It just doesn't seem like he fights with the same sort of passion that he used
to have for it.
I think it's inevitable.
A certain guys,
they have a certain amount of time in this game and after a while it's just,
you know,
you hear him talk about it and he says,
it's God's will and this is really more into religion these days then than he
is,
I think into going out and fucking people up,
you know?
So I've always been a fade or fan,
you know,
I thought the days when he was dominating and pride,
he means one of the most exciting guys in the world.
Watch.
It was amazing man.
But all fighters,
they go through a cycle of the,
the greatest of all time.
They all go through a cycle where they're almost unbeatable and after awhile
there's some deterioration or the talent pool increases,
which is one of the things that I,
I certainly think happened in the UFC.
You know,
I think the talent pool has gotten bigger and bigger and reseal over doom that
the first loss.
You just cannot fuck around for breezy over dooms guard.
You can't,
you can't,
you can't get play.
You can't play cute with that dude.
He just locks your shit up.
When I talked to,
um,
Ryan Parsons about Fabrizio,
when he talks about how king,
Mo and mayhem and all those guys were training with breeze you,
he said none of the ground and pound works,
none of it for research just moves you around,
just puts butterfly hooks in on you,
moves you around.
They can't handle.
And they can,
they can't beat him up on the ground.
He's just too fucking dangerous.
That debt have you wait long build with a sick guard like he has.
If anybody gets on top of that guy,
when they're on your good luck,
you're in a fucking terrible situation.
That guy on his back and you're on top of him and you're fucked.
You're in a bad spot unless he's tired because overing within his guard.
That's true.
He was really tired and is not really human size.
What's the latest with Overeem?
Um,
they say they have some reason for why he tested over a certain number and they
also say that the number he tested,
um,
may not have been accurate as this,
as the rumors.
This is everything,
by the way,
is completely hearsay that I'm saying.
Um,
I didn't have any direct from Overeem information.
Some people believe that he is going to be able to be licensed to fight and that
they'll,
I don't know.
We're going to find out on April 24th and April 24th.
That's when he has his,
uh,
his hearing.
I don't know if the commission makes a decision on the same day.
I think they do,
but I'm not sure.
Um,
but then we'll probably find out what the fuck they decided to do.
and what the situation is.
Exactly.
If it's something he took,
if something's not true,
if it's a mistake,
it was tainted sample.
I don't know,
man.
I don't know.
But you know,
I mean,
if you're going to look at a guy that you would think that might be using
something that makes you look awesome.
How about the most awesome looking body in the history of the world?
I mean,
who's got a better look at body that Overeem Cindy Crawford and Meg Ryan for
girls.
For Girls?
Yeah.
Don't you think?
Oh Man,
I had a back garage.
No fighters had a boy.
If she,
she was hot when she was young.
Had a professional fighters.
Who's got a better about it then over him?
Nobody.
I like Sam's doubt.
Do you like that?
He's got a buddy as well.
It was as big as over him.
He'd be equally impressive.
Vladimir Klitschko was on the flight.
The flight from a Fort Lauderdale sat right next to the Dunkin.
Holy Shit.
Is that guy big?
Whew.
He's the heavyweight champion and one of them,
the two brothers,
you know there's two white guys or the heavyweight champions right now.
We live in a fucking crazy world.
Two white guys who are doctors.
They have PhDs.
How dead is that?
Heavyweight division and boxing,
so how much their man and just David,
nothing.
He's,
he's big in Europe and has a couple other guys,
but no coach coach,
just boxing everybody's fucking face on.
When was the last time we had a heavyweight paper view?
That's a good question.
I get Klitschko coach go.
I think as paper reviews.
I don't know.
Maybe.
Maybe he doesn't.
Maybe just fights.
I know he's huge in Germany because he lives in Germany,
speaks like I fucking a hundred different languages or something.
Shit.
He's a super genius.
He was playing chess on his iPad all the way back from Fort Lauderdale.
Kimbo might be the heavyweight champion.
Kymeta and Kemp Kimbo against Klitschko.
Come on.
Did you see?
A lot of people think that his last fight was a dive.
Have you seen all the criticism online?
I didn't even pay attention.
The guy came online that fought them and defended himself and made a lot of
sense to me.
I mean,
sometimes people just get caught and it looks,
it looks like a dive,
but it's just you're tired and you get clipped on the jaw and your shit just
goes.
It gives out on your,
it is possible,
but there's also a lot of dives out there in this world.
A dude right now is a perfect time for Kimbo.
He could take over that heavyweight division.
There's no,
how do you imagine this?
Nobody.
Vladimir Klitschko did that going to be a huge fight and kill.
You go against flat.
Oh my God.
You really think that Kimbo can hang with Letterman Klitschko than it would be.
Just numbers wise would be huge.
I bet you're right.
I bet for pay per view numbers by saying,
well,
we'll make a out of it.
I say,
know
what?
If Kimbo just really becomes good at it.
You know what?
If all the,
you know,
working on take downs and all that shit.
Well that's just not his thing.
He's got a bad knee.
You saw the youtube videos,
the guy has a left hook.
Yeah.
When you've got a bad knee,
apparently it's got like one neat,
it's like bone on bone.
It's like,
remember they did a thing on it,
on the ultimate fighter there.
The doctor did an MRI on or some shit and I was like,
you know,
you've got a real deterioration of your cartilage in your ligament,
so all that leg kick in and all that,
you know,
sprawling and shit and Jujitsu.
Maybe that's not for him because his niece so fucked up.
But if he could just stand and throw those hands,
it's sort of an offender would fight Kimbo that would be a big imagine that of
Anders still fighting.
He's like,
how old is he?
That would be a huge paper.
Be Fine.
He's got to be like 48 or 49 right.
It's something like that.
Who would have ever thought,
I remember when he's fighting Riddick Bowe remember those fights back in the
day?
Yeah.
Those were crazy wars with a small dude with a huge heart and a big guy that was
real talented but didn't train that hard and they just fuck it.
Went to a war.
Whoa,
whoa.
Was talented man.
But he just never had the work ethic like Holyfield Dad,
he just never could completely get again.
Then Gelada came along and just fucked up his life.
A lot of fucked him up.
Apparently they said that a lot of beatings with the really,
the beginning of the end for him,
he should never lost it.
Go out in the first place,
the first fight,
a lot of beat the shit out of him and then dropped him with body shops,
the nuts over and over again.
Like it was purposely hitting him in the nuts to get out of the fight.
It was a weirdest thing ever.
And that was it for Riddick Bowe like after that,
he was never really the same guy again.
Those are the days,
dude,
the days of the heavyweight division in boxing when it was like,
that's what we look forward to.
You know?
Remember Michael Dokes and remember all those dudes when Tyson came along,
just cleaned out that whole division.
Pink Glynn Thomas and Roy Nelson could take over boxing.
I bet he'd come a lot of dudes,
man.
Hell yeah.
Roy Nelson could beat a lot of dudes.
That guy has got an incredible channel.
Imagine how good his chin would be with boxing gloves.
Yup.
His Chin is good with MMA,
with knees.
He takes solid.
Nice.
The face,
dude,
Roy Nelson versus butter bean.
That could be on the undercard of Kimberly.
A vendor.
That's actually a great card.
That's a great card.
Holy Shit,
but it would never happen.
Roy.
Roy would never get out of his UFC contract just for that because not that many
fights.
There'd be huge though.
There's a lot of money in boxing.
We need a heavyweight division.
How many times we started this music is billing at least at times.
I'm trying to get you to put it together,
man.
Use your connections.
Talk to Bob,
Bob Arum.
If you're listening out there Kimbo versus a Vander or Kim and then the winner
of that gets Klitschko boom.
Boxing.
Boxing is back.
Roy Nelson.
Nelson again to who did we say?
Well,
I don't see any hands.
Butter,
butter bean.
Oh Dude,
forget about it.
Forget about it.
It's butter beans still fighting.
So big man.
He's,
he's way bigger than it used to be.
It used to be enormous.
He's huge now.
I,
he,
he had a cooking show
for a while.
He's working on a Carl's Jr.
Yeah,
he could put away some fucking food.
That's a big boy.
Big Alabama boy.
He was working in American top team too.
He's trying to do some MMA for awhile.
Remember if our gangs pseudo leg locked him.
Yeah.
All Right Ladies and gentlemen,
we've talked your ear off.
We appreciate the fuck Outta you.
I appreciate everybody that came down to Fort Lauderdale Improv.
It was,
it was,
it was humbling.
It was awesome.
The enthusiasm.
It's been a just fucking incredible.
And uh,
I couldn't be more appreciative of all this shit.
I don't want anybody to think that this is anything that I've ever taken for
granted because we've been having a great fucking time.
Fort Lauderdale has been awesome.
And this week I'm going to film my next comedy special at the Tabernacle on four
20.
Uh,
yeah.
It's so corny.
I had to do it.
It's going to be in the Georgia,
Atlanta,
Georgia at the Tabernacle theater.
I believe it for a show.
I don't think there's any tickets left,
but the second show,
there's some tickets off.
There's an eight o'clock and 10 30.
I'm going to use them both.
So don't think that if you come to the eight o'clock,
you're not going to get on.
I'm going to use a bolt and most likely it'll be a lot of different shit.
And I'm going to get to,
I'm going to do a question in the answer thing at the end,
just like I did on my first CD.
So we're going to have a good fucking time.
And then the next night it's Rashad Evans and John Jones.
You dirty bitches tomorrow.
Tommy Segura joins us on the podcast.
Yay Tommy.
And um,
and that's it.
You fucking freaks.
We Love Ya.
We were happy as fuck that you are enjoying this podcast and all those people
out there that send us positive energy and positive text messages and tweets and
all this shit on Facebook.
Couldn't be happier that I'm connected to all you guys and couldn't be happier
that we're not all sort of together creating something that's more positive.
Death squad for life bitches.
Thanks for the Po to the fleshlight for sponsoring the podcast.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the fleshlight.
Enter in the code name Rogan,
and you will get 15% off the number one sex toy for men.
Oh sweet baby.
And thank you to honest.com.
The kettle bells are coming.
The kettlebells are coming.
We've been talking about it.
I'll show them to you.
They're,
they're sick as fuck.
The first,
uh,
we're going to,
there's going to be two waves and kettlebells.
Uh,
the first wave is going to be traditional kettlebells and then the second wave
is going to blow your fucking mind.
You're going to sell kettlebells,
son,
you don't even know.
Wait,
wait till you see what,
what we're calling them.
I can't tell you shit son cause it's,
I'll tell you as soon as we get off there,
but it's,
it's nuts.
It's cool.
It's crazy cause Joe kettles to do you do the weight.
You can just have to see it.
You just have to see it.
It's ridiculous.
I'll explain it to you.
You'll see it.
You'll know.
But thank you to [inaudible] dot com for everything they do.
It's the coolest company I've ever been involved with.
Bar none.
Go to o,
n n I.
T get in there and check out all the information about nootropics.
If you are interested in nootropics,
please Google the subject.
There's a lot of information both positive and negative about it,
but I can tell you personally that I have been using nootropics for a long time
and I notice a very tangible difference when I'm using them.
I use them before every comedy show.
I used them,
I like to use them before I work out.
There's a bunch of different stuff.
We have it on at.com the big one is Alpha brain is if I had one supplement that
I could take other than like vitamins and minerals one,
and you know,
if I could limit myself even as far as athletics supplements go,
I would take Alpha brain that is ma,
this is my all time favorite supplement.
It hundred percent works for me.
It's totally subjective though.
Everybody's body is different.
I don't know what you know.
I don't know if you're a sensitive to good or bad.
I don't know if you're as into supplements as I am.
If you're not,
if you buy it,
if you don't feel it was worth it,
you get 100% of your money back.
You don't have to return the product.
You just say,
this stuff sucks.
All right,
that's it folks.
We will see you tomorrow.
We'd love the fuck out of you and praise Odin.
[inaudible].